data generated by companies and
individuals like us has grown massively
over the past decade as per statista.com
the global data are generated and
consumed would reach 181 zettabytes by
2025. organizations need to gather and
analyze such large volumes of data and
look at their past business performances
as well as results and use that
information to prepare for the future
that essentially is data analytics so
hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video tutorial of data analytics full
course 2022 by simply learn this video
will help you gain all the necessary
skills and knowledge within 12 hours to
become a data analyst in 2022 our
experienced trainers will take you
through the course but before we begin
if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us so let's look at the topics we'll be
learning in this video
we'll start by understanding the basics
of data analytics and learn the top 10
data analyst skills for 2022. after that
we learned the top 10 data analysis
tools followed by looking at a use case
in Python
next you'll get an idea of how to
manipulate and visualize data using our
packages and then look at time series
analysis in our then we'll shift our
Focus to understanding data analytics
using Excel pivot tables and learn to
create Excel dashboards moving further
you'll see some interesting data
analytics projects related to
coronavirus Spotify World happiness
report and Olympics finally we will
learn some of the important questions
that are asked frequently in data
analytics interviews so let's get
started hi guys
welcome to another video tutorial by
simply loan in today's session
we will look at data analytics for
beginners
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to another mission update
in this video
we will discuss what data analytics is
and the need for data analytics
then we will look at the different ways
in which data analytics can be used
followed by the various steps involved
in the data analytics process
after that
we will get an idea about the different
tools used in data analytics and the
companies using data analytics
moving forward we will see a case study
on how Walmart uses data analytics for
better customer service and finally we
will perform a regression analysis in R
to predict sales based on the
advertising expenditure from three
mediums tv ads radio ads and newspaper
advertisements
so what is data analytics
companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour this data could be in the form of
log files web server and transactional
data as well as various customer related
data
also data has been generated at a rapid
rate from social media websites and
applications such as Facebook Instagram
Twitter and WhatsApp
companies want to use this data to
derive value out of it and make business
decisions
that's where data analytics comes into
use
data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen Trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business predictions
data analytics improves the speed and
efficiency of your business
a few years ago a business would have
gathered information manually performed
statistical and complex analytics and
Unearthed information that could be used
for future decisions
but today that business can identify
insights on the Fly for immediate
decisions
most organizations have big data and
many understand the need to harness that
data and extract value out of it
so they use a lot of modern tools and
Technologies to perform data analytics
some of the tools I will discuss in
detail later in this tutorial
now that we have looked at what data
analytics really is let us understand
the ways in which you can use data
analytics
first is improved decision making
data analytics eliminates a lot of
guesswork and manual tasks from choosing
the right content planning marketing
campaigns and developing products
organizations can use the insights they
gain from data analytics to make
informed decisions leading to better
outcomes and customer satisfaction
it gives you a 360 degree view of your
customers which helps you understand the
behavior completely enabling you to
better meet their needs
second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to tailor customer service
to their needs provide more
personalization and build stronger
relationships with them
your data can reveal information about
your customers communication preferences
their interests their concerns and more
it helps you give better recommendations
for products and services
next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production
when you have an improved understanding
of what your audience wants
you waste less time in creating ads and
content that don't match your audience
interests this helps you optimize your
campaigns create better content
strategies and hence improve results
and finally we have effective marketing
when you understand your audience better
you can Market to them more effectively
data analytics also gives you useful
insights into how your campaigns are
performing so that you can fine tune
them for optimal outcomes
you also find out the probable customers
who are the most likely to interact with
a campaign and convert into leads
now let's discuss the various steps
involved in the data analytics process
as you can see on the screen there are
five process steps now let me make you
understand each of this one by one
so the first step is to understand the
problem
before starting with the analysis you
need to understand the business problem
and Define your goals
asking questions at the outlet is vital
because this would address issues such
as how can we reduce production costs
without sacrificing quality what are
some of the ways to increase sales
opportunities with our current resources
do customers view our brand in a
favorable way answers to these questions
will help you build a clear road map
with new Creative Solutions
also try to find out the key performance
indicators and consider the Matrix to
track along the way
the second step in the process is data
collection
after you have finalized your goals it's
time to start looking for your data
data collection is the process of
gathering information on targeted
variables identified as data
requirements
the emphasis is on ensuring accurate and
right data is collected data collection
starts with primary sources which are
also known as internal sources this is
typically structured data gathered from
CRM software Erp systems marketing
automation tools and others these
sources contain information about
customers finances gaps in sales
Etc
under external sources you have both
structured and unstructured data so if
you are looking to perform a sentiment
analysis towards your brand you would
gather data from various review websites
or social media apps
the next step is to clean the data
the data which is collected from various
sources is highly likely to contain
incomplete duplicate and machine values
so you need to clean these unwanted
redundant data to make it ready for
analysis
so to generate accurate results
analytics professionals must identify
duplicate and anomalous data another
inconsistencies that could skew the
analysis according to a report sixty
percent of data scientists say most of
the time is spent cleaning the data
while 57 percent of data scientists say
it's their least enjoyable task
now the fourth step in the process is
data exploration and Analysis
once data is cleaned and ready you can
go ahead and explore the data using data
visualization and business intelligence
tools
you can also use various Data Mining and
predictive modeling techniques to
analyze the data and build models
you can use different supervised and
unsupervised algorithms such as linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k n k-means clustering and lots
more to build prediction models for
making business decisions
and the final step is to interpret the
results
this part is important because it's how
a business will gain actual value from
the previous four steps
interpreting the results will help you
find unseen Trends and patterns in the
data and gain insights you can have a
validation check if the results are
answering your questions these results
can be shown to your clients and
stakeholders for better understanding
and business collaboration
now that we have looked at the various
steps involved in data analytics let's
now see the different tools that can be
used to perform the above steps
so as you can see we have seven tools
including a few programming languages
that will help you perform analytics
better now let's discuss them one by one
first we have python
python is an object-oriented open source
programming language that supports a
range of libraries for data manipulation
data visualization and data modeling
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via the python
package index which is py the repository
of python software
python provides the default package
installer called pip or pip
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
time series then you have scipy for
Technical and scientific computations it
also provides scikit-learn which is a
machine learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it also has pi
torch and tensorflow for deep learning
up next we have r
R is an open source programming language
majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis it provides a range
of libraries for data analysis and
visualization some of these libraries
are ggplot Thai DeVos plotly deployer
and carrot
then we have tableau
Tableau is a popular data visualization
and analytics tools that helps you
create a range of visualizations to
interactively present the data build
reports and dashboards to Showcase
insights and Trends it can connect with
multiple data sources and give hidden
business insights and patterns
then we have a competitor of Tableau
which is power bi
power bi is a business intelligence tool
developed by Microsoft that has an easy
drag and drop functionality and supports
multiple data sources with features that
make data visually appealing
power bi supports features that help you
ask questions to your data and get
immediate insights you can also forecast
your data for predicting future trends
so the next tool is Click View
click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision making
it provides social media Discovery and
interactive guided Analytics
it can manipulate huge data sets
instantly with accuracy
up next we have Apache Spark
Apache spark is an open source data
analytics engine to process data in real
time and Carry Out complex analytics
using SQL queries and machine learning
algorithms
it supports spark streaming for
real-time analytics and Spark SQL for
writing SQL queries
it also has spark ml lib which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms and then it has
graphics for graphical computation
and finally we have SAS
is a statistical analysis software that
can help you perform analytics visualize
your data write SQL queries perform
statistical analysis and build machine
learning models to make future
predictions SAS empowers our customers
to move the world forward by
transforming data into intelligence
SAS is investing a lot to drive software
Innovation for Analytics Gartner has
positioned SAS as a magic quadrant
leader for data science and machine
learning
moving on to the applications of data
analytics
data analytics has been used in almost
every sector of business these days
let's discuss a few of them
first we have retail
customers expect retailers to understand
exactly what they need and when they
need it
data analytics helps retailers meet
those demands
retailers not only have an in-depth
understanding of their customers but
they can also predict Trends recommend
new products and boost profitability
retailers create assortments based on
customer preferences invoke the most
relevant engagement strategy for each
customer optimize supply chain and
Retail operations at every step of the
customer Journey
the second application is on Healthcare
Healthcare Industries analyze patient
data to provide life-saving diagnosis
and treatment options
they also deal with healthcare plans and
insurance information to drive key
insights using analytics they can
discover new drugs and come up with new
drug development methods
Advanced analytics allows healthcare
companies to improve patient outcomes
and experience
cancer cells and diabetic retinopathy
can be discovered using Medical Imaging
at number three we have Manufacturing
for manufacturers solving problem is
nothing new
they fight with difficult problems and
situations on a daily basis
from complex Supply chains to motion
applications to labor constraints and
Equipment breakdowns they deal with such
problems on a regular basis
using data analytics manufacturing
sectors can discover new cost saving and
revenue opportunities
the fourth application is related to the
banking sector
Banking and financial institutions
collect vast volumes of structured and
unstructured data to derive analytical
insights and make sound financial
decisions
using analytics they can find out
probable loan defaulters customer churn
out rate and detect fraudulent
transactions immediately
the final application is based on
Logistics
logistics companies use data analytics
to develop new business models that can
ease their business and improve
productivity
they can optimize routes to ensure
delivery reaches on time in a cost
efficient manner they also focus on
improving order processing capabilities
as well as Performance Management
with that
now let's look at the companies using
data analytics on a daily basis
so if we have the e-commerce giant
Amazon
then we have Accenture followed by the
American healthcare service organization
Cigna
then we have the American supplier of
Health Information Technology Solutions
Services devices and Hardware Cerner
followed by Target and anti-virus
company McCafe
next we have Rapido which is an Indian
bike rental company based in Bangalore
after that we have Flipkart and the
world's largest retail company Walmart
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
in this we've broken up in so many ways
but we're going to start with looking at
the most basic questions that you're
going to be asking in data analytics and
the first one is you want descriptive
analytics what has happened hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center if we have 500
tourists in a forest and you have a
certain temperature how many fires were
started how many times did the police
have to show up to certain houses all
that's descriptive the next one is
predictive Predictive Analytics is what
will happen next we want to predict this
is great if you want to have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store in
a certain day based on the temperature
coming up in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive Analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in City development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income and we want that income to
be commercial based what kind of
commercial buildings do we need to build
in that area that are going to bring
people over do we need huge warehouse
sales Costco sales buildings or do we
need little mom pod joints that are
going to bring in people from the
country to come shop there or do you
want an industrial setup what do you
need to bring that into industry in
there is our car industry available in
that area if it's not a car industry
what other Industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime
and area with education what kind of
education are we going to use to help
people understand what's going on so
that we lower the rate of crime and we
help our communities grow better that's
all prescriptive it's all guessing we
want foresight into how can we make it
happen how can we make this better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager shareholder or the data
scientist coming in you really need to
understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past here we go into
Predictive Analytics predicting the
total units that would sell and the
profit we can expect in the future gear
up for how many employees we need how
much money we're going to make and
prescriptive analytics finding ways to
improve the sales and the profit so we
can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
hello everyone we welcome you all to
this video by simply learn in today's
session we will learn a really
interesting topic that is the top 10
skills to become a data analyst in 2022
in today's Digital World data is being
generated by companies and individuals
every second so the role of a data
analyst holds supreme importance
so if you're looking for a career in
data analytics this video will help you
learn what a data analyst does and the
various skills you need to possess to
become a data analyst in 2022
before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learned Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's look at the agenda for this video
first we will understand who a data
analyst is then we will understand the
top 10 data analyst skills for 2022.
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the companies hiring data analysts
so now let's understand who is the data
analyst
a data analyst is a professional who
collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to
extract insights and useful information
from it
they acquire data from primary or
secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business problem
now with this basic understanding of who
are data analyst is let's learn the top
10 data analyst skills for 2022.
at number one we have structured query
language or SQL SQL is a top skill that
every data analyst should have data
analysts use SQL commands and functions
to store process analyze and manipulate
structured data using relational and
nosql databases
they also build data models and write
complex SQL queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
some of the popular databases a data
analyst should be familiar with are
Microsoft SQL Server MySQL postgresql
and IBM db2
the second important skill for a data
analyst is Microsoft Excel
Microsoft Excel is one of the most
popular and oldest spreadsheet
applications for creating reports
performing calculations and analyzing
data data analysts need to know how to
handle tabular data in Excel so they
should be aware of features like sorting
filtering conditional formatting pivot
tables what-if analysis and functions
such as sumifs and countifs
the third crucial data analyst skill for
2022 is data cleaning and wrangling
usually the data collected by analysts
from various heterogeneous sources is
often messy and contains a lot of
missing values
so it is always crucial to clean the
data and remove noise missing or
erroneous elements
it is also important to format data
using tools and methods before using it
for analysis
they are responsible for data mining as
well
the data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are Excel power query and open
refine
the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and statistics
data analysts often work on data for
higher Dimensions that are greater than
three in order to interpret such data
they need to be good at linear algebra
and calculus they also build predictive
models and statistical models such as
linear regression logistic regression
knife base and k-means clustering in
order to understand the working of these
algorithms they must have knowledge
about statistics and probability
coming to the fifth important skill for
a data analyst in 2022 we have
programming
data analysts need to master at least
one programming language preferably
python or Raj in order to work with
complex business problems analysts need
to write scripts and user-defined
functions to automate tedious tasks
Python and R language provide a
collection of different libraries and
packages such as numpy pandas deeply
matplotlib ggplot which data analysts
can use to discover Trends and patterns
from complex data sets
after this we have data visualization as
our sixth skill another data analyst job
role is to visualize large volumes of
data and prepare summary reports and
dashboards for the leadership team and
clients so that they can make timely
business decisions
to do this data analysts use various
data visualization tools such as power
bi Tableau and click View
using these tools data analysts can
integrate various data sets apply joint
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs
the seventh skill for a data analyst is
industry knowledge
data analysts should have good knowledge
and understanding of the industry or
domain they are working in for example
if you're working in a healthcare domain
you need to know how Healthcare
analytics can be applied to improve
patient care you should have knowledge
about the challenges faced in healthcare
and how you can leverage data and
analytics to solve the issues only if
you have strong industry knowledge can
you try to improve the business
the eighth skill that is important for a
data analyst in 2022 is problem solving
a business deals with several problems
on a daily basis data analysts should be
ready to face those challenges data
analysts are expected to use their
problem solving skills work with the
team troubleshoot what went wrong and
provide an effective solution via data
analysis
a data analyst with good problem solving
skills can help a business identify
current and potential issues and
determine a viable solution based on the
data it collects
the ninth scale on our list is
analytical thinking
data analysts need analytical thinking
ability to break down a complex problem
into simple components and resolve these
components one by one
it is a must-have skill for data
analysts
analytical thinking includes deciding
the parameters that need to be
considered for defining data sets
analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies
coming to the 10th skill among the top
10 skills for a data analyst in 2022 we
have communication
data analysts don't just interact with
computers and programs they also
interact with team members stakeholders
and data suppliers
so good communication skills are
essential
data analysts also present their
findings in front of an audience who
might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms so
those were the top 10 skills our data
analyst needs to possess in 2022 do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comment
section below
now let's look at the salary of a data
analyst
according to Glassdoor the average
annual salary for a data analyst in the
United States is 69
517 dollars while in India you can earn
nearly 7 lakh rupees per random
finally let's look at the top companies
that are hiring data analysts in 2022.
here we have the consultancy and big4
giant Deloitte and the pharmaceutical
company Cerner Corporation then we have
the tech giant IBM retail company
Walmart and the e-commerce leader Amazon
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session after extensive research we
have come up with these top 10 data
analysis tools here we will look at the
features of each of these tools and the
companies using them so let's start off
at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel all
of us would have used Microsoft Excel at
some point right it is easy to use and
one of the best tools for data analysis
developed by Microsoft Excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
Excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formulas it is one of the
widely used tools be it in a small or
flat setup
the interface of Microsoft Excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly Excel works with
the windows version of excel supports
programming through Microsoft's Visual
Basic for applications VBA
programming with VBA allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in VBA
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts by doing so it's a lot easier
to analyze data especially while
creating graphs and other visual data
representations the visualization can be
generated from specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use Excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the UK based company Ernest
and Young then we have Urban Pro Wipro
and Amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number nine we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
Commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and Analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer we have the Caribbean
Airline Leeward Islands Air transport
next we have the United Health Group the
American online payment company PayPal
and the Austrian Telecom company
MobileComm so that was all about
rapidminer now let's see which tool we
have at number eight
we have talent at number eight
Talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in Big
Data integration Talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and Big Data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
bones Talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools Talent
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the process is
gradually speed up
Talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases SAS and other Technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and Cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of Talon the
companies using Talent are Air France
L'Oreal cab Gemini and the American
multinational Pisa restaurant chain
Domino's
next on the list at 7 we have nine
Constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept nime
has been used in pharmaceutical research
and other areas like CRM customer data
analysis business intelligence text
Mining and financial data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the nine features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature use of
gdbc allows assembly of nodes blending
different data sources including
pre-processing such as ETL that is
extraction transformation loading for
modeling data analysis and visualization
with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
9 server automates workflow execution
and supports team-based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from Becca H2O carers Park
and our project
nime allows analysis of 300 million
custom addresses 20 million cell images
and 10 million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are United Health Group asml fractal
analytics atos and LEGO Group let's now
move on to the next tool we have SAS at
number six
SAS facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of SAS
using SAS better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation as a SQL
SAS allows you to access through
Microsoft Office by letting you create
reports using it and by Distributing
them through it
size helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using SAS we have companies like genpact
IQ via Accenture and IBM to name a few
that was all about SAS
so for all those who joined in late let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number 10 we have Microsoft Excel then
at number nine we have rapidminer at
number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine and at number six we
have SAS so far do you all agree with
this list let us know in the comment
section below let's now move on to the
next five Tools in our list
so at number five we have both R and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth position
R is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research python is a high level
programming language which has a python
data analysis Library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from Excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the Python
Jupiter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both R and python
when it comes to the availability of R
and python it is very easy both are in
Python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
I used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both are in
Python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both R and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using R we
have Uber Google Facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have Amazon Google and
the American photo and video sharing
social networking service Instagram
that was all about RN python
thank you
at number four we have Apache Spark
Apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
Analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including Hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
Swift Amazon S3 and Cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs
Apache spark is designed to accelerate
analytics on Hadoop while providing a
complete Suite of complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine and stream processing
so this is how the interface of Apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of Apache Spark
stores data in the ram hence it can
access the data quickly and accelerate
the speed of analytics spark helps to
run an application in a Hadoop cluster
up to 100 times faster in memory and 10
times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in Java Scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high-level
operators for interactive querying spark
code for batch processing joint stream
against historical data or run ad hoc
queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of SQL queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics Etc Apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
Lockheed Martin and eBay are some of the
companies that use Apache spark on a
daily basis
at number 3 we have another important
growing data analysis tool that is Click
View
click view software is a product of
Click for business intelligence and data
visualization click view is a business
Discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with click view you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
Gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of Click view looks like
now talking about its features
clickview provides interactive guided
analytics with in-memory storage
technology during the process of data
Discovery and interpretation of
collected data the clickview software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
clickview uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the ram of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery
social data Discovery offers to share
individual Data Insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report clickview
supports mobile data Discovery within an
HTML file enabled touch feature which
lets the user search the data and
conduct data Discovery interactively and
explore other server-based applications
click view performs olap and ETL
features to perform analytical
operations extract data from multiple
sources transform it for usage and load
it to a data warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career in Click view are
Mercedes-Benz cab Gemini Citibank
cognizant and Accenture to name a few
at number 2 we have power bi
power bi is a business analytics
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app a
website
it can connect to hundreds of data
sources and bring your data to life with
live dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface
power bi is built on the foundation of
Microsoft Excel and has several
components such as Windows desktop
application called Power bi desktop and
online software resist service called
Power bi service mobile power bi apps
available on Windows phones and tablets
as well as for IOS and Android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi
it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language power bi helps
users see not only what's happened in
the past and what's happening in the
present but also what might happen in
the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as Excel Tech CSV Oracle SQL Server
PDF and XML files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like SharePoint Office
365 and Dynamics 365 as well as other
non-microsoft products like spark Hadoop
Google analytics sap Salesforce and
MailChimp
some of the companies using power bir
Adobe AXA Carlsberg capture menai and
Nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
Gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified Tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
Tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in Jan 2003
in Mountain View California
Tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence it can create a
wide range of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of Tableau are
Tableau desktop Tableau public Tableau
server Tableau online and Tableau reader
this is how the interface of Tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with Tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
Tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the Fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple SQL queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and highlighters
table Tableau allows you to ask
questions spot Trends and identify
opportunities with the help of Tableau
online you can connect with Cloud
databases Amazon redshift and Google
bigquery
the company is using Tableau are
Deloitte Adobe Cisco LinkedIn and the
American e-commerce giant Amazon to name
a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools since this is data
analysis with python
we got to ask the question why python
for data analytics I mean they're C plus
plus there's Java there's dot net from
Microsoft why do people go to python for
it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in Java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of be a little lazy
in your programming that doesn't mean
that it can't be set that way and that
you don't have to be careful it just
makes means you can spin up a code much
quicker in Python the same amount of
code to do something in Python A lot of
times is one two or three or four lines
where when I did the same thing say in
Java I found myself a 10 12 13 20 lines
depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible so
there's our flexibility because you can
do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine to using a pi spark into
the spark environment and spread that
across hundreds if not thousands of
servers across terabytes of data or
petabytes of data so it's very scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
Java has a huge collection of libraries
C has a huge collection of libraries.net
does and they're always in competition
to get those libraries out Scala for
your spark all those have huge
collection of libraries this is always
changing but because Python's open
source you almost always have easy to
access libraries that anybody can use
you don't have to go check your
licensing and have special licensing
like you do in some packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick Google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics and the big five
players are numpy pandas matplot Library
scipy which is going to be in the
background so we're not going to talk
too much about the scientific formulas
inside pi and PSY kit
so numpy supports in dimensional arrays
provides numerical Computing tools
useful for linear algebra and Fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers and you can even have a grid
inside a grid or data it's not even
numbers because you can also put words
and characters and just about anything
into that array but you can think of a
grid and then you can have a grid inside
a grid and you end up with a nice
three-dimensional array if you want to
talk three-dimensional array you can
think of images you have your three
channels of color four if you have an
alpha and then you have your X Y
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine watching a
movie well now you have your movie clips
and they each have their X number of
frames and each of those frames have X
number of X Y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work within
dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas useful
for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame and if you're
working with big data and you're working
in spark or any of the other major
packages out there you realize that the
data frame is very Central to a lot of
that and you can look at it as a Excel
spreadsheet you have your columns you
have your rows or indexes and you can do
all kinds of different manipulations of
the data within including filling in
missing data which is a big thing when
you're dealing with large pools or lakes
of data where they might be collected
differently from different locations
and matplot Library
we did kick over the sci Pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
for of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matplot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in Python several
toolkits extend matplot Library
functionality there's like a hundred
different toolkits to extend matplot
Library which range from how to properly
display star constellations from
astronomy there's a very specific one
built just for that all the way to some
very generic ones we'll actually add
Seaborn in when we do the labs in a
minute several tool kits extend matplot
Library functionality and it creates
interactive visualization so there's all
kinds of cool things you can do as far
as just displaying graphs and there's
even some that you can create
interactive graphs we won't do the
interactive graphs but you'll see you'll
get a pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves get our
hands in on what we're doing now there's
a lot of options when we're dealing with
python you can use pie charm as a really
popular one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones I
used to use netbeans which is kind of
lost favor I don't even have it
installed on my new computer
but the most popular one right now for
data science Now pycharm is really
popular for python General development
for data science we usually go to
Jupiter notebook or anaconda and we're
going to jump into Anaconda because
that's my favorite one to go to because
it has a lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like so with Anaconda we have our
Jupiter lab we have our notebook these
are identical Jupiter lab is an upgrade
to the notebooks with multiple tabs
that's all it is and we'll be using the
notebook and you can see that pycharm is
so popular with python that we even have
it highlighted here in Anaconda as part
of the setup
uh Jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running Jupiter notebook and then you
have your different environments I have
we're going to be under main Pi 36
there's a root one and I usually label
it Pi 3 6. the reason is is currently as
of writing this tensorflow only works in
3 6 and not in three seven or three
eight for doing neural networks but you
can actually have multiple environments
which is nice they're they separate the
kernel so it helps protect your computer
when you're doing development and this
is just a great way to do a display or a
demo especially if you're looking for
that job pull up your laptop open it up
or if you're doing a meeting get a
broadcast up to the big screen so that
the CEO can see what you're looking at
and when we launched the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be Chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python3 and this just creates an
Untitled uh version of this and you can
see here I'm actually in a simply
learned folder for other work I've done
for simply learn
and that's where I save all my stuff and
I can browse through other folders
making it really easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics just so I
can remember what I was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now uh so let's go ahead and jump
in there and take a look at some of
these different tools that we were
looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the numpy uh the least
visually exciting and I'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as NP that is the
most common numpy terminology
and let's go ahead and change the view
so we also have the line numbers I don't
know why we probably won't need them but
I'm looking for easy reference and then
we'll create a one dimensional array we
just call this array one
and it equals NP dot array and you put
your array information in here
in this case we'll spell it out you can
actually do like a range in other ways
there's lots of ways to generate these
arrays but we'll just do one two three
so three integers
and if we print
our array one
we can go ahead and run this
and you can see right here prints one
two three you can see why this is a
really nice interface to show other
people what you're doing with the
jupyter notebook
so this is the basic we've created an
array this is a one dimensional array
and then the array is one two three one
of the nice things about the Jupiter
notebook is whatever ran in this first
setup
is still running it's still in the
kernel so it still has the numpy
imported as in p and it still has our
variable
arr1 for array 1 equal to NP array of
one two three
so we go to the next cell
we can check the type of the array we're
just going to print
we say hey what's what what does this
setup in here and we want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one and let's go ahead and run
that
and it says class numpy ND array so it's
its own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class the
probably the biggest thing you do I
don't know how many times I find myself
doing this because I forget what I'm
working on and I forget I'm working with
a three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array and I have to reformat somehow so
it works with whatever other things I
have and so we do the array shape the
ray shape is just three because it has
three members and it's a one-dimensional
array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access stick with the print statement
if you actually put a variable in
Jupiter notebook and it's the last one
in the cell
it will be the same as a print statement
so if I do this where array one of two
it's the same as doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our Jupiter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one
and it's three so there's our print
Space 2 and we have 0 1 2
2 equals 3 we can easily change that so
we have array one of place two
equals five
and then if we print our array one
you can see right down here when it
comes out it's one two and five
and there I left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list it'll always print the variable if
you just put it in like that
that's a Jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pi charm I've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple Dimensions
so we'll do an array two-dimensional
array and this is again a numpy array
and in the numpy array
we need our first Dimension we'll do one
two three
and our
second dimension three four five and you
can see right here that when we hit the
uh we'll do this we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of 1
and then we can do let's do a zero it
doesn't really matter which one actually
let's do uh two there we go and if I run
this it'll print out five uh because
here we are this is zero uh zero one two
three is under zero Row three four five
is on our one row now we start with zero
and then the two zero one two goes to
the five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot shape
and if we do array 2 of shape
we'll go and run that we'll see we have
two rows and each row has three elements
a two-dimensional array two three if you
looked up here when we did it before it
just had three comma nothing when you
have a single entity it always saves it
as a tuple with a blank space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array two of let's go what is
it one
comma 2
let me run that we get the five you can
also count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see I just kind of Switched
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot
now two is the last one zero one two
it's the last one in there we can count
backwards and do minus one and if we run
this we get the same answer whether we
count it as uh let's go back up here
whether we count this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus one minus
two minus three and you can see that if
I change this minus one to a minus two
and run that
I get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus two so there's a lot of different
ways to reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array
it's really a cool tool it's got a lot
of things you can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not values and
we'll call this array s for Strings
equals NP dot array
put our setup in there brackets and
let's go
China
India
USA
Mexico doesn't matter we can make
whatever we want on here and if we print
that out
we run this you can see that we get our
numpy of Ray China India USA Mexico it
even gives us our D type of a U6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array R for
range
just to kind of keep it uniform NP dot a
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data Maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do integers
and we're going to do a setup from 0 20
skipping every other one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at zero and counts up to 20. so
if you're used to another language where
explicitly says less than or less than
equal to 20 like for x equals zero X
plus plus uh X is less than 20. that's
what this is it just assumes X is less
than 20 on here
and if we want to create a very uniform
uh set you know zero two four six what
happens if I want to create numbers uh
from 0 to 10 but I need 20 increments in
there we can do that with line space so
we can create
um an R we'll call this l
equals I don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so I don't know why
I'm creating unique identifiers for it
but we'll do NP
Lin space
and we're going to do 0
to 10 or 0 to 9. remember it doesn't it
goes up to 10. and then we want to let's
say we have 20
different
um
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it and
here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years and we got to divide it in
the middle and you can see it does it
goes 0.52 remember the others are 10 on
the end so it goes up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's NP dot random if you're doing
neural networks uh usually you start it
by seeding it with random numbers
and we'll just do NP dot random and
we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are zero to one so you'll see that
all these numbers are under one and you
can easily alter that by multiplying
them out or something like that if you
want to do like zero to a hundred you
can also round them up if it's integer 0
to 100 there's all kinds of things you
can do but generates a random float
between 0 and 1. and you have a couple
options you could reshape that or you
can just generate them in whatever shape
you want and so we can see here we did
three and four and so you can see three
rows by four variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set I have had this
come up many times where I need to start
off with zero and I don't know you know
because I'm going to be adding stuff in
there or it might be 0 and 1 or 1 is if
you're removing the background of an
image you might want the background is
zero and then you figure out where the
image is and you set all those boxes to
one and you create a mask so creating
masks over images is really big and
doing that with a numpy array of zero
and we can also uh
give it a space
and we'll just do this all in one shot
this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do uh two
comma three
and so we run this
forgot the asterisks around it I knew I
was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this you can see here we
have our 10 zeros in a row and maybe
this is a mask for an image and so it
has uh two rows of three digits in it so
it's a very small image a little tiny
pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way instead of creating a
mask of zeros and filling in with ones
uh maybe you want to create a mask of
ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do just like we did before with the
three comma four and when we run this
you'll see it's all ones and we could
even do this even we'll do it this way
let's do
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors and you can so creates
quite a large array there for doing
pictures and stuff like that when you
add that third dimension in
um if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and we'll do 0 1 2
and then in this array we actually print
right out we want a repeat so you can
actually do a repeat of the array and
maybe you need this array
let's repeat it three times
so there's our repeat of an array repeat
three times
and if we run this
you'll see we have zero zero zero one
one two two two
and whenever I think of a repeat I don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit three times the second digit
I really always think of it as zero one
two zero one two zero one two it catches
me every time but the actual code for
that one is going to be tile and again
if we do a range three
and we run this you can see how you can
generate one zero one two zero one two
zero one two
if you're dealing with an identity
Matrix we can do that also if you're big
on you're doing your matrixes and we'll
just identity
I guess we'll go ahead and spell it out
today any tricks
and the command we're looking for is
um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity Matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our Matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
Matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too we talk about
matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have the diagonal
so we can do an NP dot diagonal
then we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal one
two three four five and there's your uh
your beginning of your Matrix array for
working with that matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array equals remember our
random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array oops there we go
five five
and just so you can see what that looks
like
helps if I don't mistype the numbers
which in this case I just need to take
out the brackets and there you go you
have your your five by five array set up
in there and we can know because we're
working with Matrix is we might want to
do this in reverse and extract the
diagonals which would be the 0.79 the
0.678 and so on
and we simply type in NP dot diagonal
and we put our array in there
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our Matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do print the shape
out you can also do the dimensions so in
Dimensions very similar to shape it
comes out and just has two Dimensions we
can also look at the size so if we do a
size on here we can run that and you can
see as a size of 25 two dimensions and
of course five by five and that was from
the shape from earlier that we looked at
there's our 5x5 shape
and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do uh random I
talked a little bit about manipulating 0
to 1 and how you can get different
answers you can also do straight for the
integer part and we'll do minus 10.
to 10
and so we're going to Generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10 we're
going to generate four of those so when
we run that we have seven minus 3 minus
six minus three they're all be between
minus 10 and 10 and there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays which is really
great because this is where they come in
here's the array and you can add 10 to
it and if I run this there takes my
original array from up here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal I had stored in Array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers I had from 0 to 1 and
adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do uh
minus 10
. we could even do
times two
and we could do divide by two
and it would it'll take that random
number we generated and cut in half so
now all these numbers are under 0.5
another way you can
change the numbers to what you need on
there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential so as an exponential
function which would generate some
interesting numbers off of the random
so we're taking them to the power I
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the um array were because we
did the random numbers up there here's
our original numbers and if you build an
exponential on there uh this is where
you get e to the X on this and just like
you can do e to the X you can also do
the log so if we're doing logarithmic
functions
that reinforced learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different array numbers
and if you're working with a log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in P log 2. you have to look it up
because this is not log one two three
four five it is Log and log 2. so just a
quick note that's not a variable going
in that is an actual command there's a
number of them in there and you'll have
to go look and see what the
documentation is but you can also do log
10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your lumpy
array you're doing a tangent activation
there's your tangent for that
and the tangent activation is actually
from neural networks that's one of the
ways you can activate it because it
forms a nice curve between from whether
you're generating 1 to negative one with
some discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into it we just put the
array back out there so we can see it uh
when we're doing this
as we're getting into this you can also
sum the values so we have NP sum
and you can do a summation of all the
values in this array and you'll see that
if you added all these together they'd
equal 12.519
and so on I don't know what the whole
setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this one of the things you
can also do is buy axes so we could do
axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axes
equals zero
and you can think of that in numpy as
the rows so that would be or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one
and now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to um
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal you're looking for
and this comes up a lot because you have
like your errors we want to find the
minimal error inside of this array and
just like the other one we can do axes
equals zero
and you can see here
0.0645 is the smallest number in this
First Column is 0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit and here
we go you can see maximum 0.79 is a
maximum on this first column and just
like we did before you can change this
to a one
on axes you can take the axes out of
here and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing and
just like we did before we could also do
axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on
and we have mean we might want to know
the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers if we have median we might want
to know the standard deviation or if we
have the average a lot of times you do
the means and the standard deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes we can also do
it across the whole array
if we're going to do standard deviations
there's also variance
which is your VAR
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means there's more
but those are the most common ones used
with data analytics and then going
through your data and figuring out what
you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices you'll hear
that terminology and a slice might be
like we have a five by five array but
maybe we don't want the whole array
maybe we want from one on we don't want
the zero in there so we got up to four
and maybe on the second part we just
want
to to row three and see this notation
right here says 1 to the end and if we
run this you can see how that generates
a single row to the end and then row two
and three now remember it doesn't
include three that's why we only get the
one column so if you wanted two and
three you would need to go ahead and go
two to four so it goes up to four
we could also do this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one oops
and when we go to -1
it's the same thing because we have 0 1
2 3 4 this is the same thing as two to
four it goes two to the last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here that we randomly
generated and we might want to um
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
axis equals one if we run this
you can see from the axes that it sorts
it
the point two being the lowest value to
the highest value by the row we can also
change this of course to axis zero if
you're sorting it by columns so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array
and we can sort that I don't usually do
that but you know I guess sometimes you
might that might come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
something now let's just go ahead and
reprint our array so we can look at it
again starting to get too many boxes up
there something else you can do with an
array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that
the rows and the column are transposed
so where
0.79.57 0.064 is a column now we've
switched it and we have
0.79.42 as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other the
full rows and if we run this you can see
how it comes up a little bit different
and we'll just do the same slice up here
so you can see how those two look next
to each other
there we go there's our slice run
and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has a one two three four five
columns now we have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this together was a
function so the original version was
transpose and this still works you can
still see it generates the same value as
just a capital T
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an XY value or we'll have an
image or something like that and it's
being read one way into the next process
and the next one needs it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening why would you flatten your
data if this is an array going into a
neural network
you might want to send it in as one set
of values instead of two rows and you
can see here is all the values as a
single array it just flattens it down
into one array
so we covered our scientific uh means
transpose median some different
variations on here some of the other
things we want to do is what happens if
we want to append to our array so let's
create a new array
you're getting tired of looking at the
same set of random numbers we generated
earlier
um and so we'll go and create a new
array here something a little simpler so
it's easier to see what we're doing
and four five six seven eight
uh that's good enough we'll just do four
five six seven eight
and if we print this array
there it is four five six seven eight
and we might want to append something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it you got to be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that
one is runtime because of the way the
numpy ray is set up a lot of times you
build your data and then push it into
the numpy array instead of continually
adding on to the array
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about appending
this way but you can certainly do it and
we can just take our array we're going
to create a new array array one
and if we print array 1 and we append 8
to it you'll see four five six seven and
then there's our 8 appended on to the
end
and if you want to append something to
an array you'd probably also want to
whoops
array one let's try that again there we
go now we have the eight appended on to
the end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to go ahead and insert
instead of appending it might be you
need to keep a certain order and we can
do the same thing we do our array
um and we're going to pin or insert at
the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one two three one two three
and we go ahead and print our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
append is inserted at the beginning
uh inserts a lot more powerful and that
you can put it anywhere in the array we
can move it to the one spot and there we
go one two three we can do a minus one
just for fun and you'll see it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one
I imagine you can do a minus zero
and run this and it turns out that minus
zero puts it back at the beginning
because that's why it registers a zero
just takes a minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers and so let's do
an NP dot delete well let's keep it a
little bit make it a little easy here to
watch we'll go ahead and create an array
three
and we'll do NP delete we're just
working with array 2
and we want to do is delete zero space
so if you look at this here's our array
2 our Raid 2 starts with one and when we
delete the space on here
and print that out we deleted the one
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
or we can do it as a slice and we can do
let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma 3 you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved as far
as where the data is coming from and
it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it so there's always a warning when we
talk about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
we'll create a array C which equals
we'll just do our our numpy array that
we just created our Olympia array 3 and
we can do copy so you can make a copy of
it maybe you want to protect your
original data or maybe you're making a
mask and so you copy the array and then
the new array make all these alterations
and change it from values to zero to one
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do array C since it equals a
copy of array three it's the same thing
one three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays
I end up doing a lot of this
and I don't know how many times I end up
fiddling with this and having a mess
so but but you do it a lot you know you
combine your raise you split them you
might need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go and create two arrays array
one array two
and I want you to note
and the terminology we're going to look
for is concatenate what that means is
we're going to take
um we'll call this a ray cat I like a
ray cat there we go our array cat our
concatenated array
we're taking array one and two
and it's very important to really pay
attention to your axes and your counts I
can't merge two arrays that have like if
their axes are messed up and I'm merging
on axis zero it's going to give me an
error and I'll have to reshape them so
you got to make sure that whatever
you're concatenating together works
and what that means
as you can see here we have one two
three four one two three four and then
five six seven eight five six seven
eight along the zero axis
these each are four values
um so it's a two by four value and if we
go ahead and switch this to one you can
see how that's that flips it a little
bit so now we have one two three four
five six seven eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if I did something like this
where this is now
there we go and we concatenate it we run
this and it gives me an answer okay
because I have two by two and I'm using
axes one but if I switch this to axis 0
where now it's got 3 and 5
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match so like I said
this one oops X is one axis one has two
entities and since we're going on axes
one or by row you can see that it lets
it merge it right onto the end there
and you could imagine this if this was a
x y plot of value or the x value going
in and the predicted y value coming out
and then you have another prediction and
you want to combine them this works
really easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops I forgot how many changes I made
there we go I'll just put it whoops I
messed up on my concatenation order here
[Music]
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation axes is
really important when you're doing your
concatenation values on here
and we'll switch us back to one just
because I like the looks of that better
there we go two rows
now there are other commands in here
um so we can do cat V
equals npv v stack
this is nothing more than your
concatenation
um but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there because it's v stands for
vertical
and so if we print out
cat
V and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack
and if you're going to have a vertical
stack you can also have an H stack
so if we change this to from v stack to
oops here we go H stack and we'll just
change this from cat to cat
and I run this
it's the same as doing axis zero the
process is identical in the background
this is like a legacy setup your v-stack
and your H stack most people just use
concatenate and then put the axes in
there because it's much has a lot more
clarity and is more more commonly used
nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover is
is kind of a data exploration and
that'll make a little bit more sense in
just a moment sometimes it comes set
operations but let's say we have an
array one two three four five six three
whatever it is I think so we generate a
nice little array here and what I want
to go ahead and do is find the unique
values in that array
so maybe I'm generating what they call a
one hot encoder and so these values then
all become I need to know how long my
bit Ray is going to be so each word how
many how many each word is represented
by a number and then I want to know just
how many of those words are in there if
we're doing word count very popular
thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
we have one two three four five six
those are our unique values
some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique we can do uniques
our unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar that we just
did up here where we uh we're doing NP
unique but we're going to add a little
bit more into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts equals
true so instead of just returning the
unique values we want to know how many
of those unique values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print
our uniques
and print
our counts
let me run that you can see here we have
our unique value one two three four five
six just like we had before and then
there's two of the first of two ones two
twos two threes two fours one five two
sixes and so on and you can go through
and actually look at that if you want to
count them but a quick way to find out
your distribution of different values so
you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and if
each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know let me just put a note up
here
we're going to start looking at
intersection
and we might want to also know
differentiation
and neither
so when we're whoops neighbor
so what we're looking at now is we want
to know hey where do these two arrays
intersect and we have one two three four
five three four five six seven we might
want to know what is common between the
two arrays
um and so when we do that we have NP
intersect
and it's a 1D array one dimensional
array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array 1 array two
and if we run this
we can see they intersect at three four
five that's what they have common
and because we're going to go ahead and
go through these and look at a couple
different options let's change this from
intersect 1D
and we'll do the same thing we'll go
ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection where they have
commonalities
another
unique word is Union of 1D so instead of
intersect
we want to know all the values that are
in both of them so here's our Union of
1D when we run that you can see we have
one two three four five six seven so
it's all the different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go is we want to know
what the set difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see
that if you remember set we talked about
that being the what they call these
things
um so the set difference
of a 1D array when we run that you can
see that one is only in one array and
two was only in one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
Array one but not in Array two we might
want to know what is in Array one but
not two and what's in two but not one
and this would be the set X or 1D on
here so we have the four different
options here where we can do an
intersection what do they both have in
common we can do a union what are all
the unique values in both arrays
we can see the difference what's in
Array one but not array two so set diff
1D and then set X or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking there's a lot of different
little mathematical things going on in
numpy a lot of this can also be done in
pandas although usually the heavy
lifting is left for numpy because that's
what it's designed for let's go ahead
and open up another python 3. setup in
here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting in my opinion a
little fun because you're actually
playing with it and you have something
to show people and we'll go ahead and
rename this we're going to call this uh
pandas and Pi plot
so pandas pipelot just so we can
remember for next time and we want to go
ahead and import the necessary libraries
we're going to import pandas as PD now
remember this is a data frame so we're
talking rows and columns and you'll see
how pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people and then
we're going to have numpy in the
background numpy works with pandas so a
lot of times you just import them by
default
Seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library so sometimes we use the Seaborn
because it kind of extends it's one of
the 100 packages that extends the
matplot library probably the most common
used because it has a lot of built-in
functionality almost by default I
usually just put Seaborn in there in
case I need it and of course we have
matplot Library as pipelot as PLT and
note we have as PD as NP as SNS as PLT
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your Imports I would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
uh it says Amber sign matplot Library
inline
that is for Jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package you'll have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the most current version of
Jupiter usually leave that out and it
will still display it right on the page
as we go and we'll see what that looks
like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the Seabourn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them just keep the
default one so we don't have to think
about it too much
and we of course have to run this the
reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and I access one of these afterward
it'll crash
the cool thing about Jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to Anaconda and run your
install for these and then just come
back and run it you don't have to close
anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car equals PD
dot read underscore CSV and then we have
the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with uh so it's
wherever you saved the file at and you
can see here I have um like my OneDrive
documents simply Learn Python data
analytics using python slash car CSV
it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a CSV file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower cylinders and so on
um and this is just a comma separated
file so each row is like a row of data
think of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in so when you start seeing the
pandas on here you realize that you are
already like halfway done with getting
your data in I just love pandas for that
reason numpy also has it you can load a
CSV directly into numpy but we're
working with pandas and this is where it
really gets cool is I can come down here
and I can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out the
head is going to print the top values of
that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and in line
because we're in jupyter Notebook I can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data and just like we expected
we have our column and it brought the
header right in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we got 0 1 2 3 4.
um you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two BMWs
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file
and you can see right here it numbered
them all the way up to
11913. oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file I didn't even look to
see how big the file was so you can
really easily get through and view the
different data in here when you're
talking about Big Data
you almost never just print out car in
fact let's see what happens when we do
if we run this and we just run the car
it's huge in fact it's so big that the
pandas automatically truncates it and
just does head plus tail so you can see
the two
um so we really don't want to look at
the whole thing I'm going to go back to
let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data it gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there I can zoom out if we want so you
can actually get a better View
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code I'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we of
course want to look at um
data types what's going on with our data
what does it look like now this you know
you show your when you're talking to
your shareholders they like to see these
nice easy to read charts they look like
a spreadsheet so it's a nice way of
displaying pieces of the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year engine fuel type is an object if we
go up here you can see that there most
of them are
like you know it's a set manual rear
wheel drive so they might be very
limited number of types in there
uh and so forth and you'll it's either
going to be a float 64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically we have here the make the
model the year the engine the size all
the way up to the MSRP
and um just out of something you'll see
come up a lot is whenever you're in
pandas and you type in dot values it
converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in a numpy array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the data is actually stored and
that's true of any of these
in this case we want car dot columns
you have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data um scientist we
want to start looking at analytical
summary of the data set what's going on
with our data so we can start trying to
piecemeal it together so we can do car
describe
and then we'll do is we'll do include
equals
all
so a nice Panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a make the model of the
year how many of each one how many
unique values of each one the top value
of each one what's most common the
frequency the mean clearly on some of
these it's an object so really can't
tell you what the average is it'd just
be the top ones the average I guess
the year what's the average year on
there all this stuff comes down here
your standard deviation your minimum
value your maximum value what's in the
lower quarter fifty percent Mark where's
that line at and what's in the upper 75
percent the top 25 percent going into
the max
now this next part is just cool this is
what we always wanted computers be back
like in the 90s instead of 5 000 lines
of code to do this maybe not five
thousand all right I built my own plot
Library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot was um
I don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram that is
the power of Seaborn now it's still
going to generate a numpy graph but
Seaborn sits on top and then we can do
the figure size this is just um so it
fits nicely on the paper on here and we
do something simple like this and you
can see here where it comes up it does
say matplot library and does subplots
and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database and
we have our engine cylinders that's
always a good one because you can see
like they have some that are they had a
null on there so they came out as zero
um maybe a couple maybe one of them had
a two cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder 12 cylinder engines but it's
got to be a Speedster or something
uh but you can see right here just
breaks it down so now you have how many
cars with how many whatever it is
cylinders horsepower and so on and it
does a nice job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom there it is it can see it all the
way across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the Seaborn SNS box plot
and we're going to go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus engine horsepower
XY plot and the data comes from the car
so if we run this we end up with a nice
box plot
you see our mid-size Compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car a
large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
Seabourn box plot or sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at what they call
pair plotting we can run that and you
can see with the Seaborn it just does
all the work for you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grit
in this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower to the year was built and
it's just flipped so everything to the
right of the middle diagonal is just the
rotation of what's on the left and as
you expect the engine horsepower gets
bigger and bigger and bigger as time
goes on so the the year was built the
further up in the year the more likely
you are to have a heavy horsepower
engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
moment to process but right away I get a
nice view of all these different
information which I can look at visually
in and kind of see how things group and
look
now if I was doing a meeting I probably
wouldn't show all the data
one of the things I've learned over the
years is people myself included love to
show all our work you know we were
taught in school show all your work
prove what you know the CEO doesn't want
to see a huge grid of graphs I guarantee
it so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're gonna I'm not really a car
person a guy in the back is obviously so
you have your engine fuel type we're
going to drop that we're going to drop
Market category vehicle style popularity
number of doors vehicle size and we have
the axes in here if you remember from
numpy we have to include that axis to
make it clear what we're working on
that's also true with pandas
and then we'll look at just that what it
looks like um from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year and so forth and we took
out the engine fuel type Market category
Etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas I
just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice spreadsheet for you you can just
look at it and view it very easily it's
also the same kind of view you're going
to get if you're working in spark or Pi
spark which is python for spark across
Big Data this is the kind of thing that
they they come up with this is why
pandas is so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns and so you can
go in here and we can actually rename
the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower this is just your standard
python dictionary
so it just Maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy here we
had engine horsepower we just won
horsepower we don't need to know it's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
and horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better and of
course we can also adjust the size a
little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control Mouse app or plus sign
you use in Chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way we
can look at the shape of the data so we
now have
um
11914 rows and 10 columns so you see
some similarities because pandas is
built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows and so we can do car and
look at this switch here we're doing a
selection this is a panda selection with
the brackets
but we want to select it based on
car.duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so it's starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access some
of the data in here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should we
might go ahead and do like a car count
just to see how many rows we're dealing
with and then right after that we might
want to go ahead and say hey let's drop
duplicates so remember we did all the
duplicates on there so car equals car
dot drop duplicates and then we can
print the head again we'll just do car
head here and you can see the data on
there looks the same as before
uh and just note that we did car equals
car draw duplicates there are commands
in here where you can do where it
changes the actual value and it works on
some of them and not on others depending
on what you're doing but by default it
always returns a copy so when we do this
we're reassigning it to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10 925. so we've removed
about a hundred cars that were
duplicated just slightly under 100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know
um car is null so it's going to count
the values of null and then we want to
sum that up and when we do that we do
the car is null function.sum we end up
with HP the horsepower at 69 have null
values and 30 have cylinders have no
values now if you don't put the sum at
the end it's just going to return a mask
with the true false of is it null or is
it not by zero and one so you're summing
up the ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value there's a lot of different ways to
fill it usually when you first start out
with the data a lot of them you just
drop your null values and you can see
here car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 1925 to 10
8 27. yeah maybe 75 or so values
so we cleaned that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to um
counting our null values we should now
have
null null values there we go and you'll
see there's zero null values
I don't know how many times I've been
running a model that doesn't take null
values and it crashes and I just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked
it's because I forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to uh finding outliers
and let's go ahead and bring that back
into our Seabourn and if you remember we
did a box plot earlier uh this time
we're going to do a box plot just on the
price and you can see here our price
value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value and then as we get up here we have
all these outliers in fact we have one
way out here that's probably a really
expensive high-end car is what we're
looking at
if you were doing fraud analysis you
would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like I said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at and we can
also look at the box plot for the
horsepower
and we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more um as you start
displaying your data or your information
to your shareholders we're going to look
at plotting a histogram for the number
of cars per brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is we have with our car go back
over here here we go we have our make
value counts largest plot and we want to
do a kind equals bar
fig size 10.5
and right off the bat we jump up here
and we see Chevrolet it's going against
what was it it's um figure race Edition
the value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts and
compared to what the different cars are
Chevrolet puts out a lot of different
kinds of cars I didn't realize that they
made that many cars or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like well what the heck am I looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars and
the different ones are put out Lotus I
guess only had a few different kinds of
cars over there very high-end cars
and then as uh doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things I
am most interested in is the
relationship between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure it
fits our graph we'll just go ahead and
set this one plot Figure Set to figure
size 2010. if you never use the matplot
library which is sitting behind Seaborn
whatever is in the PLT this is what's
loaded it's like a canvas you're
painting on so the second you load that
Pi plot as PLT anything you do to that
is affecting everything on it
uh and then we want to go ahead since
we're using Seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable C
for
relationships or correspondence
and car dot c-o-r-r that's a correlation
in Seaborn on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with Seabourn
let's put it into a nice heat map if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
means we're just using color as part of
our uh
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the Seaborn
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart we'll talk a little bit about
the color here in a second it prints out
a nice chart this is a chart I look at
as a data scientist these are the
numbers I want to look at and we'll just
highlight one of them here's cylinders
versus horsepower the closer to one the
higher the correlation so 0.788 pretty
high correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is
I'm betting if you looked at the year
versus uh horsepower we just look at
that one here's year and horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them uh you don't actually add them but
if you combine them you'll start to see
an increase in Horsepower per year and
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 0.78 is
a positive correlation you might notice
if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage so if we go here to horsepower
to mileage you get a nice negative we'll
do cylinders that's a bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus 0.6 so it's a negative
correlation the closer to -1 the more
the negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction uh
pandas goes Way Beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since pandas sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
Seaborn pretty extensively sitting on
top over our pie plot so keep in mind
that our PI plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here we couldn't even if you had a
sole course in it there's just so many
things hidden in there depending on what
your domain you're working on but you
can see here here's our Seabourn and
here's our matplot library that's all
our Graphics that we did and then the
Seabourn works really nicely with the
pandas we really like that
so that wraps up our demo part for today
let's learn about data manipulation in R
and here we will learn about deep layer
package and when we talk about this
d-plier package it is much faster and
much easier to read than base R so D
player package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt or data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deployer by just
calling in library function and this can
be used for grouping by data summarizing
the data adding new variables selecting
different set of columns filtering our
data sets sorting it selecting it
arranging it or even mutating that is
basically creating new columns using
functions on exit existing variables so
let's see how we work with d player now
here I can basically get the package
here so I can just say install dot
packagesdp player now we already see the
the package here which is showing up so
I will just select this one I can do a
control enter and that will basically
set up the package package deployer
successfully unpacked so that is done
now you can start using this package by
just doing a library D player and this
was built it shows me my version of R so
let's also use a inbuilt data set that
is New York flights 13 so we can do
install.packages and that will search
and get that relevant data set
I can again Call It by using Library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day departure
time schedule departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data which can help us in
understanding the data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have so this is fine
now we can start using deployer and in
that we can use say filter function if
we would want to look in for specific
value now here we have the column as
month so I will do a filter now I am
creating a variable F1 I'm using the
filter function on flights which we
already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is 0 7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on F1
which shows me the data wherein you have
filtered out all the data based on month
being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say F2 filter flights and here we will
say month is equal to 7 day is 3 and
then look at the value of F2 if you are
interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month 7 and days
three you could also look into a more
readable format by using view on F2 and
that gives me my selected result so we
are just extracting in some specific
value we can keep extending this so here
we can say flights is what we would want
to work on I'm using the filter function
so I can straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view I can also do a view in
this way I can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this I am
saying filter I would want to look at
the flights month being 0 9 day being 2
and origin being LGA and then that shows
me the value here and obviously you can
scroll and look at all the columns and
if you see the origin column it shows
the selected value so now we have
filtered out our data based on values in
three different columns now what we can
also do is we can use and or we can use
or operators so I could have done this
in a a little different way so I could
have said head which shows me initial
result I will do a flight So within my
head function I am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flight's data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we're given a value and I'll
say and and I'll again say flights
wherein I will select the day being two
and and remember when you talk about and
it is going to check if all the values
are met true so then you say flights
origin LGA and you look at the value so
in this way I can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific in specifying all the columns
it makes the code more readable so let's
look at the values and here you are
looking at head which shows me based on
month day and then you can look for
further columns for other variables that
is origin being LGE now what we can also
do is we can do some slicing here to
select rows by particular position so I
can say slice and I would want to look
at rows 1 to 5 and I can do this so you
can always assign or look at the view of
this I can just do here so when I did a
slide one is to 5 it shows me my entries
for one to five now similarly we can do
is slice 5 to 10 and now you are looking
at 5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to add it to your existing data
frame or you would want to add a new
column so this is where you use mutate
which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate so it's pretty simple so you
create a variable over delay now I would
want to do a mutate so that it adds a
new column so I am selecting my data
which is flight I will call the new
column as overall delay and then
basically
I can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure DeLay So let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view and you could have just look at
flights if you would want to compare so
you can look at the flights and this one
would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay the
computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a summarize
and what we can do is we can look at our
data and we can say on what basis we
would want to summarize this particular
data so we can do a summarize function
now summarize on flights I will say
average airtime and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I'm
using inbuilt function called mean I
will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average airtime and this one I
will look at mean of a time so let's see
if there is a a Time column I might be
let's look at this one and I will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
a time not the arrival time so air time
is how much time it takes in air for
this particular flight and we will want
to use the trans summarize function not
the transmute so summarize flights
average airtime and this one we will
calculate the mean of average airtime
and I will also do a n a removal which
is I am saying true so let's do this and
that basically shows me the average
airtime is 151 I can also do a total a
time where I am doing a summation of
values or I can get the standard
deviation or I can basically get
multiple values such as mean
I can say total air time where I am
doing a summation and then I can look at
other values which is if you would want
to put in standard deviation here you
could do that so let's look at the
result of this summarize and this
basically allows me to get some useful
information which is summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or
all three of them now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of Mt
cars and that is basically my data set
on empty cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder power of this and your
horsepower and various other
characteristics or variables in this
particular data set so here we can say
let's do a grouping by gear so there is
a column called gear so I will call it
by gear I will look at my data set and
then what I'm using here which you see
with these percentage and greater symbol
is called
piping so that basically feeds your
previous data frame into next one so
this is sometimes useful and you can get
this by just saying Ctrl shift and M and
you can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set where I
did a head or I could have done a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more readable format and that
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty cars I'm using the
piping and then I am saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column now
I can again use the summarize function
where I would want to Now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so I am doing a summarize and here
I am going to say Gear 1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column
and then I'm saying Gear 2 which is mean
well you could give some meaningful
names to this and let's look at the
value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the gif
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear and I'm
again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear we had
grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set Mt
cars but now within this particular data
which was grouped by gear I will take
this data set I will use the piping and
I will summarize it where I am saying
within this particular data set I would
want to get the sum or I would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values so what you're doing is you
are either looking at your original data
set or you are looking at the data which
was already grouped and then you can
look at the values now here what we can
do is we can Group by cylinder say might
be you are interested in looking at data
which is summarized based on the
cylinder column you can do that and then
for this buy cylinder I am doing a
piping where I am using the summarize
function and summarizing will then be
done based on the mean values of the
gear column or the horsepower so let's
do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample underscore n
function and Sample underscore
fraction for creating samples so for
this let's take the flights data set
again and we would want to get 15 random
values now that is done and it shows me
15 rows with some random values from the
data what you can also do is you can do
a portion of data by using sample
underscore fraction and here I'll say
flights I'll say 0.4 which will return
40 percent of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
might be you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use a range which is a
convenient way of sorting then your base
are sorting so for range function
let's do a view based on a range so we
will work on the flights data set which
we have and here what we would want to
do is we would want to arrange the
flight status set which is based on year
and departure time and we are doing a
view out of it so that basically gives
me the data which is arranged based on
your ear and departure time now I can do
a head to give me some highlighting of
that data now the piping operator what
we are using
can be used in these ways also so here I
will say DF I will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
DF which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are creating a variable called result
here now that has the arrange function
so what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so I would want to sort
the data but what data would I sort so I
will use sample n which will give me
some portion of the data or some sample
data now what is that sample data so
here we are using nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here now this filter will work on
DF
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20 I will
say size is 5 and I would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so I'm using the Des on this
particular mileage column by default it
is always ascending so let's get the
result out of this which will basically
show me the mileage details in a
descending order so this is my data
frame and now we can look at the result
what we have created
so just do a view or do a head and look
at the view so here you see mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi assignment so
I can say filter
wherein I'm going to use DF which was
assigned Mt cars I am going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then I
say B which is going to get a sample out
of a and I just want five random values
so let's look at that so we have B which
is
going to get a
set of five values from a now I will
create a result variable which will
arrange B which is sample data in a
descending order now let's look at the
result of this and that basically shows
me what we were seeing earlier so you
can do a multi assignment where you can
create a variable get a sample out of it
and then basically whatever is that
result you can arrange that or sort that
in a descending or by default ascending
order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator so piping so here I will say
result I am passing in my DF that's the
data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your D
plier with multiple assignments or using
your nesting to filter out the data you
can also do a a range which is to sort
the data you can get some random samples
out of it you can summarize the data you
can also summarize the data based on one
or two or multiple columns and you can
use some inbuilt functions to summarize
the data based on some functions which
are applied on the variables or on the
columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my data
set and if you would be interested only
in particular column then your D player
also allows you to either we can do a
filter or we can simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
our data so for example I'll say DF
underscore I'm interested in mileage I'm
interested in Horsepower might be I'm
interested in your cylinders in this and
for this one what I can do is when I
would want to do a select I can
basically say
selected DF let's call it some name I
can say control shift M which is for
piping and then basically what you can
do is you can do a select and you can
choose your columns so I was interested
in mileage I was interested in
horsepower
I was interested in cylinder and here
what I'm doing is I'm using a select
where I can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and I'm sorry here we will have to give
it DF this is where you are passing in
your data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a DF or head on DF
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns I
could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four or something else but
when you do a select you are selecting
specific columns so view always gives
you all the columns head gives you
highlight but then select can be useful
when we are interested in looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use the player for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tider and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation done
using your tider package let's learn
about that IDR package which makes it
easy to tidy your data and this
basically helps you creating a more
cleaner data so which is easy to
visualize and model now this comes with
the mainly four functions so you have
gather which makes your data wide or it
makes wide data longer so that is
basically used to stack up multiple
columns you have spread function which
makes long data wider that is stacking
the data together or stack if you would
want to unstack the data to data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes and then your spread can
spread the data across multiple columns
you have separate which is function with
splits single column into multiple
columns and to complement that you have
one more function which is unite and
that combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used in your tider
package so let's look how we work with
this so let me bring up my R Studio here
now for this first is let me just clean
up my screen here doing a control l so I
will install the package it is already
installed but we can just do a control
enter and then
I can say do you want to restart R prior
to reinstall Store install I'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package did tidyr the rest
idrs has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library function
and that was built under R version 3.6
now I can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say n is
and then we basically would say we will
call it white now that's the variable
name I'm using the data dot frame
function I am saying ID which will be 1
to n so that will take the values from 1
to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector Phase 1
phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it now that's done we
can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has phase dot 1
phase.2 and phase.3 now we can use our
function so for example we can work with
gather that is reshaping the data from
wide format to Long format and basically
you can say stacking up multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here I'll
call it long I am working on White I am
using the piping
functionality and then I'm using gather
so this one I will say what will be the
data which I will use so we are using
wide as a data frame
then I am saying response time so that
will be basically one more column and
then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so I'm saying from Phase
1 to phase three so let's do this and
once this is done let's have a look at
our variable long so this one shows me
that I have an ID column
I have the response time column and I
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
tagged in so you have phase dot one
phase.2 and phase.3 so I have all the
columns have been stacked here so all my
data so now I have totally 30 entries in
this one so this is basically using your
gather function now sometimes we may
want to use a separate function now
separate function is basically splitting
a single column into multiple columns so
which we would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in as the columns we
selected then I am saying separate I
want the face column and then I would
say when I separate the columns what are
my column names now I could also give a
separator by giving a comma and then
mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the column which we used so we were
doing a face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
Target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
Target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use a
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here we will call
it long Unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phase
Target number and we want to have a
separator between them so let's
basically do this and now let's look at
the result of this Unite
so you see you have the face and Target
merge together so you have phase dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have United multiple
columns so this is one more function of
your tider which helps you basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way now then you have your
spread function and this is basically
for unstacking so that is if you have if
you would want to convert a stack to
data or if you would want to unstack the
data which is of same attributes spread
can be used so that you can spread the
data across multiple columns so it will
take two columns say key in value and
spread it into multiple columns so it
makes long data wider so we can look at
this one we will say long unite I'm
using the piping I will use the spread
function I'll work on the face column
and response time and let's do this and
then let's do a view on this so it tells
me our data is back in the shape as it
was in the beginning so these are four
functions
which are very helpful when we work with
tider package
so let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about R which can
be used for your visualization now one
thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it so the efficient way or
effective way to understand what is in
our data or what we have understood in
our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are actually two
types of data visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand the data and then
you have explanatory visualization which
helps us to share our understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data and visualization the
key is to keep all the potentially
relevant details together now the
objective when we talk about exploratory
data analysis is to help you see what is
in your data
and the main question is how much
details can we interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic uh plotting
you have bar plot which is used to plot
data using rectangular bar so you can
say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency of the data are basically used
to look at the central tendency of the
data you have box plot which is used to
represent data in the form of quartiles
you have GG plot which is a package
which enables a user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plotly or
plot l y it creates interactive
web-based graphs via the open source
JavaScript graphing library now before
we see some examples here let's also
talk about when you talk about plotting
let's also try to understand what kind
of plots you can have and what kind of
techniques you have so let me open up my
R Studio here
now for example I can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one so here I can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what I can do is I can
install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then I
can simply do a plot wherein I am doing
a plot on chickweed data set so let's
see what does that show it summarizes
the relationship between four variables
in chick weight data frame which is in
our built-in data set package now from
these plots we can see for example
weight very systematically over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets now
when we talk about explanatory data
analysis or visualization that shows
others what we found in the data this
means we need to make some editorial
decisions what features we would want to
highlight for emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a
data set using Library
then I can simply create using plot
function to take generate a simple
scatter plot of calories with sugar from
us serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid Graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools
now you also have latest Graphics which
is general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push viewport if I
would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data viewport I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have x axis y-axis
given some points here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can basically create a
simple grid Graphics based plot here now
there are different other options which
we can use to create plots now before we
go into understanding how you create
plots let me just give you a brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different plots now for
example we have a bar chart which is a
graph which shows comparisons across
discrete categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value and
height of the bars are proportional to
measured values Now to create different
kind of charts you can use ggplot which
is a package for creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of Tidy words ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then TG plot will use
sensible defaults and this basically
makes it a powerful and flexible tool
now here
are different options when you use your
GG plot such as you can use geom or what
we call as geometric objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have Scatter Plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have quartile for
continuous X violin for richer display
of distribution and Jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where I would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one where we are using
Library function to get the ggplot2
package then basically we would want to
look into the mileage data we would want
to look at the structure of it and then
we can basically get the Tidy verse
package finally we can create a bar
chart using jio underscore bar and we
can basically also mention what would be
in x axis now you can also give
different colors to basically add more
meaning to your data you could also go
for stacked bar charts so here we are
actually telling ggplot to map the data
in the drive column to fill the
aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic access class and I am saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using geom underscore bar so
you can also have dodged bar
in your ggplot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using your
position as position underscore Dodge
okay now you can obviously use your
different packages which are inbuilt and
you can create your bar charts and you
have other kind of graphs such as line
graph which is basically a type of graph
that displays information as a series of
data points connected by straight line
segments such as this one and for this
one we are using if you see jio
underscore line now you can also create
a scatter plot which is a two
dimensional data visualization that uses
points to graph the values of two
different variables one in an x-axis one
on y-axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which I
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data basically
looking at your large amount of data or
for a single variable you would be
interested in saying where is more data
found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph how close
the data is towards its mid point or
what we call as mean median mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
pie chart for different products and
units sold so you want to create a graph
for this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and labels so let's do
this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a simple
plot now I can also find out what is the
percentage and then basically I would be
interested in plotting the pie chart
which takes X which takes the labels
which will be the percentage which we
are calculating here by doing a round
function and then you can basically give
details to your graph you can say what
color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be in your chart
what are the values and then basically
fill up the colors so let's run this one
and that shows me the percentage which
was calculated and it gives me the
details and we can always have a look at
our plot now if you would want to go for
a 3D pie chart then you can get the
package which is plotrix let's use that
by calling in the library function let's
pass in some data to X and let's give
some values or labels which will make
more meaning to the data and then let's
plot the 3D graph so I'm saying Pi 3D
here where I'm using X and labels
then I'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say Main and by chart of countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we are
created using the C function creating a
vector and then let's create a histogram
for this one
where I would say xlab what would be
your data around x axis what is the
color what is the border and here I am
creating a simple histogram
which as I discussed earlier will always
show your values on the x-axis and
y-axis is more of frequency and then you
can look at the set of values and what
is their frequency and we can basically
use this histogram for exploratory data
analysis look at the data try to
understand what is the central tendency
of your data values now we can also give
some limits by using the x-lim and Y Lim
and then I can also specify what is the
limit so we have given some values here
wherein we have said your X limit is 0
to 40 and Y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one which
we had created this one based on the
frequency had taken the limits but we
can assign limits explicitly by giving
this and then create a histogram which
makes more meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have ozone
solar wind temperature month and the day
so this is the kind of information we
have in the air quality now let's use
the plot function to draw a scatter plot
where as I mentioned you would be
interested in analyzing variables and
see what is the relationship between
them so to plot a graph between ozone
and wind values so we will say plot we
will say the data which is air quality
from that I would be interested in the
ozone column or ozone field and the wind
field I can create a plot based on this
now I can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for tick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar from your air quality and that
basically shows me the frequency of
solar values and we can then try to find
out what is the made what is the mean
what is the standard deviation and so on
you can also look at your histogram and
try to understand if it is left skewed
and right skewed so we can do that now
here let's get the temperature out from
this particular data set let's create a
histogram on temperature and that
basically shows me the frequency of the
temperature values and what values have
the most frequency or most occurrence
now you can create a histogram with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your X lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the Border
what are the breaks you would want to
have for your bars and you can simply
create a histogram using this so This
basically takes the breaks which we have
given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70 70 to 75
and so on so this is basically creating
a histogram with non-uniform width and
it purely depends on the kind of values
what you have now you can also create a
box plot which sometimes helps us in
understanding the the data quartiles
also understanding our outliers so you
can create multiple box plots based on
the data from air quality so we'll
select all the data and then we'll do
some slicing on the data so let's create
a box plot which tells me the values and
if you look at these points here like
single dots these are basically your
outliers we can learn about that more in
later sections so you can use your GG
plot to library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install.packages and get ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart R and
I can say yes so let it get the package
I think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that I have the
library function
and let's do a attach where I'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use ggplot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on the
cylinders which is there in your data so
we can always look at what does our data
contain and what kind of values or
features are available in the data now
let's create a box plot we will also use
the coordinate function and that
basically gives me based on the data so
I've changed the coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the
y-axis and cylinders on the x-axis
now I did a coordinate flip and that's
like your transpose function so you have
created the box plot but you have just
flipped the coordinates you can create a
box plot and then say fill which is the
factor of cylinder so that can be used
to fill up the values in your box plot
now what we can also do is we can create
factors so we have learned about factors
earlier which is usually used to work on
categorical variables so here let's
create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am you
have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data what is the field or the
column we are interested in what is the
level of values there and what are the
labels for those values right so we have
learned about factors
you can always look into the previous
section and learn more about factors now
let's create a scatter plot by using the
ggplot function again we will use the
data as MD cars I will go for mapping
option and then I will give my
Aesthetics that is what would be x what
would be your Y and you also would want
to use what kind of function you are
using so let's go for geompon point and
that basically helps me in creating a
scatter plot now you can create a
scatter plot by factors so here we will
say GG plot so notice in all of these
cases depending on the kind of data you
have depending on the kind of plot you
are interested in you will use the GG
plot and then basically a function with
that or the inbuilt package so here I am
saying data is empty cars I am going for
mapping which basically will take the
values for your X X and Y what is the
color and the coloring will be done
based on the factor values now if you
remember factors will obviously have
some levels and those levels will
basically help you in differentiating
between your categorical variables so
I'm saying as dot Factor on cylinder and
then I am using geompoint to basically
create the scatter plot so let's do this
and I can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
which says must at least one color from
the Hue palette so let's look at that
one so the error which we were facing
when we gave color as the factor values
was because when you look at these
factors which were created with some
labels if we look at the values of these
it tells me there are any values in that
particular column similarly your gear or
similarly you can completely look at the
complete data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have care now these have
some we have created some labels but
these have any values so what we can do
is we can create a scatter plot as we
did earlier by giving the Aesthetics and
that's a simple scatter plot wherein I'm
also using geompoint so that I can have
these points by defaults or with
defaults you can also give a color
specific basically if you would want to
have different kind of data in the same
plot or I can create Scatter Plots by
different sizes by giving a size or I
can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your Scatter Plots now let's also see
how you can visualize one more data set
which is MPG so I can also do it in this
way where I set GG plot 2 and then pass
and look at the data set what we have
here you can just do a view on this to
see what my data contains if the fields
have any any values if that's going to
affect your plotting so now what we can
do is we can create a bar plot or a bar
chart so I'm saying GG plot the data
would be as we have given in previous
lines that is GG plot 2 MPG then I will
say what should be in my Aesthetics and
what kind of
chart are you going to create so I'm
saying geom underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked in the same bars and we are
still using the same data we are going
for Aesthetics which is class and then
when you say geome bar which creates
your stack bar we will use fill which is
Drive
and we can always go back and look at
our data for example you can always look
into this so you have the drive column
here and you are also working on this
complete data set so let's go ahead and
create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we are
still going to go for a stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful you can use this by using
geompoint where you are mapping and you
are specifying what are your Aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class and we have different
classes and based on that my points have
been colored now you can also use a plot
lyu or plotly Library so let's install
this one
I will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then I can access that package using
Library function and then create a
variable to which you are assigning your
plot underscore l y plot so data is
empty cars what will be your x-axis what
will be your y-axis and details on your
marker which we have given wherein I
will give a list which is size color
which is a combination and then you have
your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where I'm
going to use plot l y
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot l y and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or how you can have your
graphics or visualization used to
understand your data obviously there are
much more examples much more ways in
which you can pass into your plot
functions or your ggplot and the inbuilt
packages which are available in R for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or explanatory
data analysis so try these graphs and
see if you can change these options and
try or create new visualizations
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session where we will
learn on time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically a mini project where we will
look at time series data and how we can
analyze it visualize it to basically
find some important information or
gather insights from the data now when
you talk about time series analysis time
series is basically any data set where
your values are measured at different
points in time so when you talk about
time series data data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example timestamp data and computer
systems event log or history of 911
emergency calls now when we work with
time series data for example here I am
taking a energy data set we can see how
techniques such as time based indexing
resampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations in electricity demand
and renewable energy Supply over time
now here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I am considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a Time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just does not have the time but it
may also have time stamp that is it
would have say hour minutes and seconds
and that can also be worked upon so
let's consider this data set and let's
work on this project where we will
Analyze This Time series data set now
here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long term Trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how blue wind and solar
power production compare with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find a lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically coal
or you have this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my GitHub
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I have
given the documentation sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your
rstudio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame
from this data set now here if you see I
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column I
am also giving row dot names and I'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as I showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
update consumption wind solar wind plus
solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just create this let's look at what does
this data frame contain and here if you
see it shows me some data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind solar wind dot solar and
that basically has n a values so there
are missing values but let's look at the
tail and that tells me that there is
some data available for wind and solar
and wind solar now we can always look in
a tabular format using View
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if I
really scroll down
I can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so I can just use view now I can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns they are of the num types
so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at Road names
and then I search for my data show me
the index column or row dot names it
tells me these are the values that's the
date column which we are seeing here now
we can access a specific row by just
doing a my data and give the index value
or row name value so let's look at that
and that shows me based on this index
you are looking at the value you can
obviously search for a different date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give range of
values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4 of
January and we can look at this one so
it shows me
these are the values so here actually
I'm not giving a range but I'm just
selecting multiple values from row dot
names now we already know that in R you
have a summary function so you can
always do a summary and that gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values so we are
looking at consumption we are looking at
wind solar and wind dot solar now this
is good but then if I would want to
really visualize the data access the
data do some analysis then it would be
good to take all the columns and then we
can later decide to change the data type
of say date column if we want to use it
so earlier I was using date as row dot
names or the name of the rows or index
what you call in any other programming
language so here I will just use my data
set and I'll say header as true I'm
calling it my data 2. let's look at the
data and this one shows me
five columns wherein My First Column is
the date consumption wind solar and so
on now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type
so it tells me that if now I'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with 4 384 levels and
these are the values so it is not in a
date time format it's a factor now what
we can do is we can convert this into a
date format how do we do that so let's
have a variable X and I'm going to use
as dot date function and I'm going to
pass in my date column so that's
assigned to X now let's look at the head
of X and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is and we
will look at the structure of X so class
already says it is date type and look at
the structure so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into X now how do I
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first I
will use so all once it has been
converted in date format I will go for
as dot numeric and here I will create a
variable called year and I will just do
a format on X which is basically of date
type and then I'm saying percentage y so
that will get me the year component out
of this let's look at the values that
shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c bind that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group by we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns now
let's look at first three rows here so
I'll say one is to 3 for my data 2 and
that shows me some data here you can
always do a head and look at the sample
of data so that basically shows me month
day your columns and then you have your
date now what we can do is we would want
to visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if I would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data how do we do it so
we can you create a line plot of
full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is I can straight away
use the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x-axis what would be on
my y-axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so I am saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every two years so from
2006 onwards to 2016 but then really
this data does not give me uh you know a
very useful way of looking at the rate
or understanding it might be what I can
do is I can use the same way but I can
give apart from x axis and y axis I can
say that
limits that is X limit is 2006 to 2018
and Y limit is from 800 to 1700 so we
can do this and let's look at this again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
I can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par
MF row now if I would want to plot I can
straight away give the column name so I
am interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so I can just do a plot in
a straight away way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on and
if you look at this this one is giving
me a pattern now here I am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but might be we
can make it more meaningful so I can do
it this way where I say my data second
column let's give access as ear x axis
y-axis is consumption now that has
changed the x-axis and y axis now I can
also give some more details I can say
type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
maybe shows a wavering pattern of
consumption over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018. I can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so I can do a
plot I can choose column second X lab
which is x-axis y-axis type is line
width giving X limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph and then basically you
are looking at the line graph now those
are the options which you can do either
you could be very specific or you could
just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I am saying
log of my data to Second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I'm changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot function
in R you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so I'll
say no I will access this by using the
library ggplot 2.
and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data 2 that's the data frame I am saying
type as o and when I'm saying line I am
basically going to use x-axis which is
here Y is consumption and let's look at
this plot so again we are back to the
one which we were doing earlier really
does not make any sense gives us some
data but then really does not give me
enough information I can
in my Aesthetics I can say access here
Ys consumption I can do a grouping and
then I can give line and plot so again
we have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I am just doing the
same thing here and I'm looking at line
type being test I'm using the GG plots
other methods such as geomline and
geompoint to give me more information
and if I look at the plot it does give
me data it tells me what are the
different values it gives me some kind
of pattern but I would still prefer the
way we were doing with plot
now we can change the color and
obviously add details to it so what we
see is when you use the plot method
which I did earlier it was choosing
pretty good tick locations that is every
two years and labels the years for the
x-axis which was helpful right but with
these data points which we were seeing
here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that really is quite
crowded
and it is hard to read you can look at
the values but then it really does not
give you enough information so we can go
for plot method but then we will see how
we can consider different data now if I
would want to plot the solar and wind
time series so let's see how do we do
that
so wind column is what I'm interested in
so first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data to
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column when
does the third column and you have solar
as the fourth and this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the N A values because we
do not want to consider the N A values
so let's let look at the minimum that
shows me
5.7757 what is the maximum value it is
826 so that also helps me in giving a
limit if I want to plot wind on y-axis I
can give a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier and let's
look at the data so that gives me some
data you can always do a zoom and you
can look at the data you can basically
expand this graph or you can reduce this
graph to see what kind of pattern we
have in consumption similarly we can
basically choose date being x-axis my
consumption being y-axis right so this
is being more specific because here we
have a range but it really does not give
me enough information so I will
basically give x-axis Y axis I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this data makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data pattern is
changing for consumption now this is for
consumption so what we can do is we can
also extract specific data so if you see
here I have done some testing where I am
saying okay I would want to get a date
specifically
I would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just changed the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it it would be good if we can convert
a column into date time format and put
that in our data frame now let's look at
the plot 2 this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern I can be more specific
where I say I would be giving date and
then the column for solar x axis Y axis
what is the type what is the Y limit and
what is the color it is always good to
specify your X and Y axis give a name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning because it
shows me some dates similarly we can do
for wind so either you do it just by
giving the column
or you give your X and Y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3 this one we can choose
plot 2 we can choose plot one and we can
put all that data in one graph so that's
when you are putting in multi plots in
one particular graph you can always do a
zoom you can always look at the data
right and this is usually useful to look
at the pattern what kind of pattern we
see what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window and let's basically plot
time series in a single year so what we
have seen is that when you look at the
plot method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data data some
kind of pattern so electricity
consumption is highest in the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in Winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year further into months we can see that
but we see a pattern which goes for
every year or every two years being
highest at a particular point of time
and then it drops down so electricity
consumption is highest in Winter and
that might be due to electrical Heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer now when you look at
electricity consumption appears to split
into two clusters we can always look at
the consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see all the values here which
are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points entries roughed around 1150
so if you really expand this you can see
you will have lot of data points at this
point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production that is
highest in summer when sunlight is most
abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge you are you know knowledge of
business to understand how this goes if
you look at wind power production that's
again highest in Winters and drops down
in summer so due to stronger winds and
more frequent storms and lowest in
summer so there is some kind of
increasing Trend in wind power
production over years which we can see
here
over the years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at is referring or showing us
some kind of seasonality that is we are
looking at seasonality in which a
pattern is repeating again and again at
regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months so seasonality when we say can
occur on other time scales so the plots
what we are seeing here they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to weekdays and weekends
so let's plot for one single year now
how do I do that so first is I will look
at my data too
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is Factor other columns which
are all numerics now like we did earlier
I'll repeat this step where I'm going to
convert the date column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what I want to do is I want to add
this
as to my data frame so I will create a
variable called mod data and this one
will have as data and I'm formatting the
value of x which is date time into month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which I created
like modified data so this is the format
I have it is in date type if you
carefully see here and then I can look
at the head of it so it saves me mod
data now we are what we did here is when
I said my data 3
so my data 3 we did a c bind and I did a
mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3.
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I'll do is I will do a subset how
does how is the subset found so I'll say
take the mod data column the value
should be greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than
2017 December 31st so I'm getting data
for one year and I'm storing it as my
data 4.
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data now let's do a plotting of this
where I will only create a plot for one
year so I'm saying my data 4 that's my
new
data what we got
so here I am going to take the first
column
which is mod data
I am going to take the third column
which is consumption so I'm looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me Jan to Jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where I have
divided the ear into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so Jan and March and May and July
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where I've broken it down into
months
so this is where you have taken time
series in a single year to investigate
further and this is what we see right
now we can clearly see there are some
weekly oscillations what one more
interesting feature is that at this
level of granularity that is when you're
looking at yearly data there is a
drastic decrease in electricity
consumption in early January and late
December during the holidays or probably
we can assume that this is holidays now
I can zoom in further and look at just
Jan and Feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
and I will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format I
will choose the starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the First Column so that is basically
your mod data so let's look into this
one and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the value so this one tells me
Jan 17 January 1 and maximum is
your
Feb 28th second month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I am giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your
x-axis y-axis
what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see I'm using X limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and Y limit so let's look at this data
and if you look at this data it is
specifically for two months and again I
can look at the pattern here what I can
also do is I can add some grid here
so I can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now I can add
a line here using AB line and then I can
basically choose what lines I would want
to add horizontally so that basically
allows me to dissect the data and look
at data in a more meaningful way I can
also add vertical lines so vertical
lines as I'm saying sequence will be
minimum maximum and I'm saying an
interval of seven so let's do this and
this basically has added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping and then it is
starting again it Peaks somewhere in the
mid of the week and again it drops down
so this is you're looking at your
consumption data right now what we can
also do is we can create some box plots
so when we looked at zooming in data for
Jan and Feb you can add some data point
points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as I showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months so we have
vertical grid lines and we have nicely
formatted tick labels that is Jan first
and 15th Feb first and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekdays and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use use
histograms and so on now moving further
we would want to explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data we can use box
plots basically to group the data by
different time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so I can just do a simple box
plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your Phi number summary that is you want
to look at your mean median you want to
look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile or 75th percentile so we can
use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
Phi number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give y-axis as
consumption and a limit for y-axis now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on year
so here I can give x-axis y axis and I
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now I'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I am giving the title as
consumption
y-axis x axis and y limit wherein I can
also use less so this is one more
feature which you can do and that
basically will give me the tick points
if you compare this one to the previous
graph so when I created this previous
graph I had two 2006 2008 and I had from
600 to 1800 and if I go for the next one
I am basically seeing more useful
information now let's look at monthly
data so I would want to group it based
on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where I'm looking at
months
and I could select a particular year or
I can just do a grouping based on months
so I can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this now
let's create a box plot for consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color let's look at the wind data
which is again grouped monthly and let's
look at the solar data which is grouped
monthly now if I zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data for
your wind for your consumption for your
solar so what we are doing is we are
creating these box plots which are
giving us values now what I can also do
is I could look at the day wise also but
before we look into this how do I infer
some information from these box plots
which are being created so this is what
we have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me year seasonality which we were seeing
in our gear plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in Winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher and then we can look
at the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in December and January
compared to November and February so
that is you look at the quartiles and
you will see that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in December and January
kill Jan and December so you can look it
from my plot now this is giving you some
idea on seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production both will give you a
year seasonality what we are seeing here
and
if basically I look at the data so it
depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to one plot per graph now I'll say
box plot I'll say consumption which is
group based on day now we know that
there is a day column and let's give a y
limit and let's look at the data so this
is where I am grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here I have given day and I have chosen
all the 31 days but I can break it down
to a week and I can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where I'm doing
a consumption group by day is higher on
weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose signal into
seasonality and long Trend now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency when you talk about
frequency in your data so we have the
modified date column which gives me a
frequency and if we really look into the
data that will tell me that the data is
on a daily basis so for that let's look
at my data 3 again which gives me data
and you can just see all the data's data
or dates are in sequence so your 22 23
24 25 26 and so on I can look at I can
access a d player package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now I can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns I
am seeing what is the minimum Phi number
summary date and consumption so date
does not show me anything because this
is not in a date format it is just a
factor but other things have the fine
number summary so we are looking at wind
solar we are looking at year and month
and day and all these columns now what
we will do is we will want to find out
the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the N A values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
n a value so I'm saying is Dot N A and
let's find out if there is any n a value
or missing value in consumption it says
0 okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are n a
similarly solar similarly wind dot solar
or wind plus solar so it gives me a
count of n a values that is missing
values and also values which are not
missing so to understand frequency what
we can do is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the First Column and
I am saying RM
n a DOT RM is true that is get rid of n
a values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date
now if I would want to get the frequency
I can basically use sequence function so
I can say from X minimum that is the
minimum value I want to look at the
frequency that is day wise and let's
just look at five entries and see if
there is a day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is day wise
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date so
similarly we can say from X minimum we
can basically look at the frequency
month wise and I can again look at five
records so that shows me monthly data
right so I can extract the data for
frequency similarly yearly data and
that's also very useful now we can
select data which has any values for
wind so how do I do it I would want to
find out the wind column and I want to
find out where the values are in a so I
will create a variable and here I will
say my data 3 and then I give a
conditional where I say is n a
in the column so let's do this now once
I've done this
once I have done this I have said that
my selected wind data from my data 3
where we said any values and I will give
the names to this so name should be in
my data 3 I'm interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns I'm interested in let's
look at first 10 records here or first
10 rows so that tells me these are the
values where wind has n a or missing
values
I can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has any solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so I
will call it cell selected wind 2 I'll
again use my data 3 I will say which but
now I am saying not any
from this column and I will select the
data for the columns so I am interested
in looking at 10 records and this shows
me not any value so no more missing
values so if I really look at this data
as I saw earlier which has n a and if I
look at these values which are not any
for the wind column so looking at these
two result we will know that in year
2011 wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do I
do that let's call it a different
variable I'll say my data 3 I will say
here when I say which where we were
saying n a here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
V
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame to a view and
this one will help me in finding out
where are the N A values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and I will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
I could select and search for one
specific value and I'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row and let's scroll
here and here you see there is a missing
value for one particular row so 13th
December 2011 has wind value 15 December
has wind value but
your 14 December does not have right
similarly we can search so there was
only one entry which was missing now
that could be for some reason might be
it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated so we have a missing value
and that can affect my plotting that can
affect my analysis so let's look at the
number of rows in this which will tell
me how many rows we have for 2011 so it
tells me 365 so that is basically the
number of days in a year now we will
find out if there were any values so we
earlier checked total number of any
values per column
that is in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values right so let's go
back here
and
we want to find out the number of any
values for a particular year how do I do
it so I can just do a sum I will say is
n a now I am interested in my data 3
wind column and I am saying my ear has
to be 2011 but I am finding out the N A
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-na
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus 1
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind 4 I will save in 3 that is
which was having all my n a and non-na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the n a value
because I am interested in finding out
that particular row so I'm saying find
out where the values n a and I want all
the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has any and
non-na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use wind 3 which has n a
non-na values but now I will say I want
the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of December there is no date
so I will select a subset of data which
includes this n a and non n a that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
so the date should be greater than 1212
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have any and
non-na values now why are we doing this
so sometimes you might have some data
for a particular column and you may want
to find out if there are any missing
values might be you want to fill them up
or replace them with something so that
is usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for a couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2016 I have
data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be a don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here I have test data
where I've extracted a subset of data I
can look at this class of this it is a
data frame structure of this it has the
columns now let's use the library
and function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward fill so filling values
can be done in different directions as I
said and you may want to First convert
your time series to specified frequency
if your data does not have a frequency
but we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I showed you and then
basically you can do a forward fill
for the values so for example if I have
my data I can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data I
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data then let's
look at the trends of the data which is
the last part of this project so
basically let's look at the trend So
when you say Trend what does that mean
so in Time series data you always have
some kind of trend so that will exhibit
some slow gradual variability in
addition to higher frequency variability
such as seasonality and noise now to
visualize these Trends what we do is we
use what we call as rolling means so we
know how our data is spread over year or
month or day but how about looking at a
rolling average and see what is the
difference so a rolling mean will tend
to smooth a Time series by averaging out
the variations and frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame you can also average out any
seasonality on a time scale equal to
window size so this will allow you to
look at lower frequency variation in the
data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I am going to my look at my data 3 which
we have been using so far now let's call
it a three day test you can give it any
name I'm going to use my data 3 I'm
using the pipen function
now I will use D plier and I will
arrange the data descending in here now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so I'll call it as
says 0 3 day so I'm going to calculate a
rolling mean every three days for my
consumption column and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a three day test
let's look at the result of this and
then I'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven is
the average consumption in 2017 from the
first date with the data point on either
side of it that is you can look at this
date so one one three zero then you look
at
you are looking at the value one three
six seven here so you look at one one
three zero one four four one one five
three zero if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this part
and that
is giving me mean okay because I have a
comment so let's basically add anything
as comment and then let's do this so it
saves me one three six seven that's what
we are seeing here right so you've got
getting a rolling average every three
days similarly if you want every five
days it takes the five values and it
gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do I do it same logic my data test
now I am using my data 3 I'm arranging
it in a descending order I am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and let's
say test 0 7 so that's a rolling average
every seven days and I'm also saying
take care of the N A values similarly
I'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's create this my data test
and let's look at the result of this so
I will use my data test I will say
arrange based on modified date now we
know there is a column called modified
date I want to just look at 2017 data so
I'm doing a filter
right and then I will choose what are
the columns I'm interested in so I will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records so let's do
this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average or the F7
day mean which is for first seven days
and then 365 you will not see the data
here but if I do a view on this I can
basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the values
these are the values for every seven day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data
now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is
spread over a period of time and that's
fair enough but now let's add some more
plot to this so I will add the seven day
rolling average to this so for second
plot to be added in the same one in R
you can use points so I will say points
I will choose 7 data column type is line
width X limit y limit and color so let's
do this and that's my pattern seven day
rolling average which basically gives me
some kind of trend
similarly I can add one more here and
this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be a very next axis and y-axis so I am
saying it will be 2500 and Y is 1800 so
my Legend will come in somewhere here I
am saying my Legend will have
consumption test and this one I can give
some names I can give what is the color
I can say what kind of
Legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
I've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here I see that my x-axis is fine but
y-axis is going a little about of my
plotting area so I can actually change
that so here I have 1800 how about
making it 1600 and let's look at this
one so we can basically uh go for this
one and start again here plot end points
and line and then add a legend right and
you can basically place your Legend
anywhere in the plot so this basically
is giving me the trend what I'm looking
at my rolling average so similarly you
can look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so seven day
rolling mean has smoothed out all week
leases personality which we were seeing
Here in My Graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so seven day will tell that
electricity consumption is typically
higher in Winter and lower in summer so
better is you break it down yearly so
here if you look at every year you can
see when it's winter when it's summer
what is the seasonality what your Trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically
uh reduces the variation so if I look at
360 by Rolling mean we can see long-term
Trend in electricity consumption is
pretty flat now that's what we are
seeing it's kind of pretty flat there is
not much variation over the years if you
really join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code
which you have here in the form of a
project.r file you can find here in my
GitHub page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing r
Excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and Reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that Excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in its spreadsheet to
obtain a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives viewer tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis now you can see
by default Excel has prompted certain
features such as formatting we have
charts totals and this one more called
tables now Excel by default has created
some pivot tables for us now the first
one you say is sum of district code by
state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and I'll give my location I'll point to
cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states so in the field list I'll
search for total population which is
this one and drag it under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A
that is largest to smallest
you can see here
in 2011 Maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected I'll choose
existing worksheet and give my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is
first let me drag
total literates column two values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
will drag City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himanchal Pradesh this
Jammu and Kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand Karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
I'll select cell Q5
and click on OK
now since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first I'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed you can just drag it from
there let me delete this
and I also want the sex ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to Value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of six ratio
click on OK
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down
go to Value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says which
states had the highest and lowest sex
ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio and if I scroll down to the bottom
you can see himanchal Pradesh at the
lowest which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert click on the pivot
table option
go to existing worksheet
click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then we want
the female graduates so in the search
bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values so I have the sum of
email graduates for each of the Cities
now since we want to find the highest
number of female graduates in the top
three cities so let me first short this
column
I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted from this you can
say that Delhi greater Mumbai and
Bengaluru are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required pivot
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing I'll click on a
location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
I'll place it on top of City so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
mail literatures onto values followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the male literacy and
female literates value
and also I want to drag
State column
two rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select
percentage of grand total so I'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011
if I come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literates
so this is another good feature
to convert your data and seat and terms
of percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it onto values
now we have the list of states and their
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell
right click go to filter and select top
10.
now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
underman and Uber islands has only one
city that is Sport player while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was dibrugar and
silchar similarly if I come down in
haryana we have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this kangavati this Rani
benoor and the school are similarly you
can see for Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields or
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivot table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
seals for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg and quantity so
let me show you how you can do that with
the help of a pivot table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze
and under calculations we have the
option Fields items and sets
if I click on this drop down I get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and
I'll select my formula
I'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values
now let's say I want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different items
like apple apricot banana similarly in
vegetables we have broccoli this carrots
corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now there's one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts click on this Excel gives me some
default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
seals if you see from the graph guava
meet the highest amount of sales now if
I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents it had the highest amount of
seals in this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert and
under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it drops
and in the x axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables limit the highest
amount of sales with
2800 rupees and at lowest was eggplant
at 900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
is an horizontal bar chart now you can
always increase and decrease the size of
this charts
let's explore
our last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which had the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of seals and the
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant with the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first seed and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the different
state names and the cities under each
state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates
next we saw how to use Slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
Rajasthan Karnataka State and saw the
total population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates one thing
marked that some of the states did not
have three cities for example Andaman
had only one city that was sport player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities that had the lowest female
graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw
how to create a calculated field called
sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw is a column
chart we also saw or looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo so this data set
was actually generated using a simulator
and is completely random it was not
validated though we have applied certain
transformations to the data using power
query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa there's North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical then we
have H which is for high priority orders
then we have M for medium priority
orders and finally we have L which is
for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order ID the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
I'll click on a cell in my data set and
then I'll go to the insert tab here we
have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is I'll drag my order year
column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order here from 2010 to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now let me show you how you can format
this chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this style
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99 000 I'll put it in the format
of millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all red you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to columns
then
let's drag the ordered ear column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go
so we have our next pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa meet the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012 then in
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
by
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table let's create our pivot chart so
I'll go to recommended charts and if you
see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here okay so these are
the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and
here you have pie chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it
and from here I'll remove the field
buttons
and I also don't need the legend so I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
I'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names we have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India there's Jamaica Italy and
all the way to the bottom if you go we
have New Zealand this Netherlands
Philippines Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our po chart so I'll go to insert
and select recommended charts
from here I'm going to select the column
chart you can see the preview here and
let me click on OK
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style 6 okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my PO table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different item names and
then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies meet
the highest amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I have selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I'm going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
you know
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Center Line at
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and I'll
also remove the outline all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I'm going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so you have also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll click on illustrations and here
I'll choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard
so I've added a few logos for each of
the charts you can see the logos here so
for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year in region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab here also
you have insert slicer and timeline
option so I'll select insert slicer here
first now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to select
all the pivot tables so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slicers we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this good report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer I'll go to report connections and
let me select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click good report connections
and then I'll select
all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
now this chart represents the revenue
that was generated in each of the
countries only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channel so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and po
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart to visualize the profit for each
year
so I'll drag my
total profit column to values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay and if you want you
can
choose the colors as well for the timing
let's have this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
and Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original po table that I had
created
go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales Channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column two rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here now based on
this pivot table let me create my PO
chart so I'll go to recommended charts
and I'm going to create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart based
on a pivot table that will show The
Profit by sales Channel only so this is
going to be a simple pie chart so I'll
first go to insert click on pivot table
and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons let me now remove the legend as
well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's just see which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I'm going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building a dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
will continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard so here you can see I have
brought my Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard so
let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I've also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid lines
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
by labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
have also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select here now so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is view table number 10
if I click on OK similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so I right click go to
report connections
here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well I'll go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
no if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
suppose you want to see the profit by
different countries so you can use the
country slicer let me just bring this to
the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly office supplies item
meet the highest amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say I want to
know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in K that is
Thousands so please mark this as
a thousand and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables and
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see a chart
has changed let me just delete this okay
so now once you change the theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I'm going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects
all right
so in this demo we saw how to create a
revenue dashboard so we created line
charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learned how to
add slicers and connected to different
pivot tables and we filtered our data to
see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see some more examples of
doing data analysis using Excel and for
that we can use some inbuilt add-ins
which can be added to our Excel sheet so
for example if you would want to do a
descriptive analytics or descriptive
analysis on your data say for example
getting your descriptive statistics such
as your mean median mode and so on so we
can do that and we can use Excel for it
so for example you can if you are given
some data say I have temperature price
of ice cream units sold and I would want
to have descriptive statistics on this
what I can do is I can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example and that that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking in here let's select say
Fields here and this is where I would
want the output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to overwrite data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5 and I can
manually change it to a 17 and let's say
okay
and
we will basically get this and I can get
rid of this so I can have it in the same
range so similarly so this one will have
to be renamed and I can basically say
price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold so we would
want to have this now let's see we can
click on data we can click on data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
need to give the range correctly so this
time our range changes to units sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it and you have basically got the
descriptive statistic so this is how you
can simply perform analysis using data
analysis here you can basically get your
descriptive statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting you need to basically make
your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
parrot or chart so we can go for
histogram and that basically gives us
the frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my bin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first row which has the heading such
as temperature and pins now we need to
give a output range so for example let's
say I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a Pareto
chart so if that's what you are
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I am
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on OK and now
you get your pins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is 120 here with
the 20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case I
can say 26
here's one thing then I can say 30
that's the second one and then basically
I can look at 22 so basically this one
does not select 20 as the lower range
but it basically selects 30 as a higher
range so I do see 20 to 30 there are
three entries similarly we can see
values of 40 and 50 and since we have
selected Pareto or sorted histogram that
shows in a descending order what is the
highest frequency of values within a
particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have three and three and
then two so this is how we can create a
histogram and we can perform an analysis
on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as I said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables are they linearly
related are they positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that we can use the correlation of your
data analysis add-in so for example you
want to find out correlation of
temperature and units sold and what we
can do is we can find out that using a
formula so for example if I search for
something like Co relation and let's
search so there is a function called
correlation which we can use and we can
use this to calculate the correlation of
temperature and units sold so for
example let's select this and that's the
function so it says give me and first
array and a second array so we are
interested in finding out correlation of
temperature and units sold so let's
select the range of values for
temperature and then I am interested in
finding out the correlation of
temperature in units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is 0.2859 say
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of values so here we are
interested in temperature and price of
ice cream so let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that let's close our bracket and
here we have the correlation value of
temperature and the price of ice cream
similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier so we can
do the same thing based on function so
this is same as correlation of
temperature in units sold so I can get
rid of this one now how do I do it using
the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into Data we need to go click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now I might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on OK and that basically gives you
that basically gives you a correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you have 0.2859 now you can also
look at units sold and say for example
price of ice cream you can look at these
particular values so if I would be
interested in finding out what is the
relationship between these variables I
can easily find using correlation so I
could be basically writing in a formula
here and selecting what are the cells so
here we were selecting A2 and C here we
were selecting A and B now might be I am
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple in Excel and
you can use either the data analysis tab
and get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to get some values based on
periodic data that means might be I am
interested in range of values I am
interested in seeing a sample of values
for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if I go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which I need to give has to be lesser
than the total input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
OK and that needs a range of values so
we will select a22 A8 now I could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case I can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say 5 that
means
I could just get one value so basically
when I'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of five I want one
value so I can then just give an output
range so here I can basically select
this cell I'll say OK and now you see it
just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is I have
said 5 it has given me the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example we want more values so let's
reduce this period to might be 2 which
basically gives me every second value so
I can basically say for example 2 and
say OK and then say okay so that shows
me 26 then you have 35 then you have 40
and then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling I'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly I want three values
and I can just give this say okay and
then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for people
hello everyone and welcome to this
interesting video tutorial by simply
learn today we are going to perform two
Hands-On projects on covet data analysis
using Python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where I'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you kovit or
Corona virus is an ongoing Global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in Wuhan China
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as SARS cove2
on March 11 2020 the who declared
covid-19 a global Health Emergency the
virus has so far infected over 22 crore
people and killed more than 4.5 million
Innocents in India there have been over
3.3 crore confirmed cases and nearly 4
lakh 41 000 deaths have been reported so
far
this data is according to official
figures released by The Union Ministry
of Health and Family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does Corona in coronavirus mean
here are the options is it a beer
B respiratory is it C crown or is it d
sun this is a very general question I'm
sure a lot of you may already know some
of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comments section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use three
different covid-19 data sets and perform
data analysis using Python and tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data in raw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in Tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals the project
will give you an idea about the impact
of coronavirus globally in terms of
confirmed cases that's reported
the number of recoveries as well as
Active cases
we will also see how India has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covid-19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using so for our first
project using python we'll be using the
first two data sets covid-19 India and
covet vaccine statewise let me open the
two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date we have the time
then we have the different state names
if I scroll down you can see we have
Kerala Tamil Nadu Delhi haryana
Rajasthan Punjab
Telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed Indian national so actually
this two data sets confirmed Indian
national and confirmed foreign National
we won't be using so in the demo itself
we'll be dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the total number of confirmed
cases
let me just
sort the B column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
I'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here this is
till
11th of August 2021
so this data was collected from Kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free we will provide the link to the
data sets in the description of the
video so please go ahead and download
them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before I jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine statewise is my
second data set
let me open it there you go so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python project you can
see we have a column called updated on
then we have the state again you can see
here there are a few discrepancies here
uh
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered we
have the sessions sites first dose
administered then we have the second
dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different vaccines
administered covaxine and Kobe Shield
you have Sputnik V
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day we have information
about transgender individuals vaccinated
and finally we have the total
individuals vaccinated each day
all right before we jump into the
Hands-On part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers is it a
Japan B Israel C Portugal or is it D
Cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch Daily News
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comment section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so I am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
Python jupyter notebook I'll just rename
this notebook as
covid
data analysis
project
I click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first I'm importing pandas SPD this is
for
data manipulation then we have numpy as
NP numpy is used for numerical
computation then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly these three
libraries will be used for plotting our
data and creating interesting
visualizations finally I'm also
importing
my date time
function all right
so I'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the covid-19 cases in India for the
different states and union territories
so I'll create a variable called covid
underscore DF DF is for data frame
I'll use my pandas Library
and then
give the read underscore CSV function
since our data sets are CSV files and
inside double quotes I'll pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so I'll just copy this location
I'll paste it here
will change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that I am going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file as a covid-19
India dot CSV
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows of the data frame I am going to use
the head function
I'll say head and within brackets let's
see I'll
pass in 10 which means I want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if I run it there you go
here you can see from 0 till 9 so we
have 10 rows of information and these
are the different
column names you have S number
date time state or Union territory then
you have confirmed Indian national
confirmed foreign National cured cases
deaths reported and the confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead let's use the info
function to get some idea about
a data set
if I run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have 18 110 rows of
information starting from 0 till 18109
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that I'll be using the describe function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75 percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so I'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore DF
I'll write PD Dot
read underscore CSV function which is
present in pandas
Library I'll move to the top and I'll
copy the
file location and we'll change the name
of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covert underscore 19
underscore India
I'm going to say covid
underscore
vaccine
underscore statewise
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covid underscore vaccine underscore
statewise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
I'll be using the head function and
inside the function I'll pass in seven
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covet underscore DF data frame we'll be
dropping a few unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed Indian national and confirmed
foreign National as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better to learn how to drop the columns
for our analysis
so I'll see
kovid underscore DF Dot
I'll use the drop function
and within square brackets I'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
we'll give a comma
within double quotes I'll say the next
column is time
my third column that I want to drop is
confirmed
Indian national
give another comma
within double quotes I'll say
confirmed
foreign National
outside the
square brackets I'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to I'll say true
I'll give another comma and say
axis equal to 1.
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error says confirmed Indian okay it
should be Indian national or not Indian
Nation
I'll just
mention it as National we'll run it
again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
Union territory cured deaths and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to date time
I'll say covet underscore DF
I'll pass in my column name that is date
I'll say equal to
PD Dot
I'll use the pandas function that is 2
underscore
date time
I'll say covet underscore DF which is my
data frame name
pass in my variable which is date
give a comma
and I'll use my argument that is format
equal to
I'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage m
give another Dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and I'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to find the total
number of active cases so active case is
nothing but the total number of
confirmed cases minus the sum of cure
cases plus deaths reported
so let's
find the Active cases I'll give a
comment
okay
I'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
I'll say equal to
covet underscore DF
and My First Column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
I'll say
covet underscore DF
then I'll pass in my keyword column
Plus
I'll again say
covid
underscore DF
and add my
death column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
it
says data frame object has no attribute
Tails this should be deal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called Active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and deaths reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas Library so in
this table we'll be summing all the
confirmed deaths and cured cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
I'll create a variable called statewise
and say PD Dot
I'll use the pivot underscore table
function
I'll pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore DF
and then
we'll give my
values parameter inside the square
brackets I'll pass in my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cured column
we'll give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
I'll say Union territory
I will
give a comma Now
and pass in my last argument which is
AGG
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be Max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
I'm going to find out the recovery read
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of cured cases divided
by the total number of confirmed cases
into hundred
so I'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets I'll
pass in my variable that I want to
create which is recovery rate
this will be equal to
the
QR cases
multiplied by hundred
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets I'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
I'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so I'm just going to
replace the names here I'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured I'll say
my deaths column
into 100 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it I'll say
statewise equal to
I'll use the function short underscore
values
so
we'll pass in my variable statewise Dot
and use the
short underscore
values function I'll say bye
I want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and I'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that I'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
I'll show you how to do it
say style Dot
background
underscore gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap so cmap stands for
color Maps this is present inside the
matplotlib Library so here you can see
there is a nice documentation on
choosing color maps in Matlab
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if I scroll down you can see there are a
number of c maps that you can use
purples Blues you have something called
Reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter cool
all these you can use whichever color
map that you want and here you can see
the different
sheets
or the gradients
okay
so I am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as I said in the beginning there are
a few discrepancies in the data set so
here you can see
this one called Maharashtra and there is
also Maharashtra Triple Star
this you can ignore even if I scroll
down you have madhya Pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for Bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
date and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data sees that Maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
Kerala Karnataka Tamil Nadu Andhra
Pradesh and uttar Pradesh so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for Maharashtra
and
if I scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if I scroll further
your Punjab the mortality rate is also
High
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
Kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
Active cases
so we'll start
I'll give a comment top 10
active
cases States
okay
so we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as Group by
so I'll first
in my data frame which is covered
underscore DF
dot followed by the group by function
I am going to group my data based on
state slash
Union territory column
then I'll say
Dot
Max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
Active cases so I have passed in my
Active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so I'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
I'll say shot by
column that is
Active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
I'll give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot and then
reset my index
for that I'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
I have
missed a square bracket here let me give
a rather square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay that is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now I'll create another variable called
fij
here we will pass in
the PLT which is for macplotlib library
and will give the
figure size
using the
fixed size
argument
is equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title will pass in the title
let's say top 10 states
with
most
Active cases in India
I'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the x axis on the y axis
I'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis I am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c bond Library
I'll say sns.bar plot
I'll say data equal to
my variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
States
this is actually active States
all right
and now
I'm going to use the
ilock function
and take the first 10 states so I'm
using a colon and then giving 10 as my
value iloc is for index location
I'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
Active cases
give another comma and say my x axis to
be
state
slash
Union territory
leave another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
I'll say line width equal to 2 and will
give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so I have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active States not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 Active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x-axis also has a mistake this
should be state slash Union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot created but as you can see here the
labels of the different states and union
territories are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
X labels I'll say plt.x
label
and my
X label would be States
then I'll say PLT Dot
by label
my y label will have the total
Active cases
and finally I'll write PLT dot show
before I run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
India into one cell
so what I'll do is I'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
I'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and will
paste it here
next let's dig the
title and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and I'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice bar plot ready on the top
you can see the title top 10 states with
most active cases and you see the edges
are in red color for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala
we also have Andhra Pradesh Gujarat West
Bengal and chattisgarh so as you can see
Maharashtra has the highest number of
active cases based on our data followed
by Karnataka Caroline Tamil Nadu at
second third and fourth place
respectively and in the ninth place we
have West Bengal in the 10th place we
have chhattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
Active cases
which are in Lacks
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths reported
so I'll give a comment
top states with
highest
debts
okay
so I'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of Active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so I'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore DF
followed by using the group by function
and I want to group my data
based on
the state slash
Union territory column
then I'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets I'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent I'll be using
single quotes
okay
I'll say dot
I'm gonna
short my
result therefore I'm using the sort
underscore values function I want to
sort it by
death column
I'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means I
want to
order my result in
descending order
then I'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that I'll give my
figure size I'll say PLT dot figure
and within brackets I'll pass in my
argument which is
fixed size
equal to
using a tuple I'll say 18 comma let's
say five
now let's give a title for that I'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
I'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels I'll just scroll down
okay
so I'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so I'm
using my c bond Library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore deaths which is
this variable
I'll give
my index location iloc
I'm going to choose
12 States the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
I'll show you once I plot this result
so in the y axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x axis we'll take
state
slash
Union territory
okay
I'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give an edge color to our bars
like we did here
so I'll say Edge color equal to let's
say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the X label the Y label
so I'll say PLT dot X label
X label would be States
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then I'll write PLT dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths now what I
specifically wanted you to see was these
discrepancies in the data you can see
here Maharashtra is repeated twice even
in our data that we collected from Kegel
Karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where Karnataka is
spelled as
k-e-r-e-a-n instead of k-e-r-n-a all
right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results I had given my index location
till 12 so we have Maharashtra Karnataka
Tamil Nadu Delhi then uttar Pradesh West
Bengal Kerala Punjab Andhra Pradesh and
satiskar
with the states that have the most
number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see the
growth or the trend of Active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala Tamil Nadu
and uttar Pradesh I can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay hello everyone
welcome to today's video tutorial by
simply learn in this video we are going
to perform a really interesting data
analysis using python on the Spotify
music streaming service platform data
set
I'll also be asking you a few questions
related to Spotify during our discussion
please make sure to answer them in the
comment section of the video
so now let's get started
Spotify distributes audio streaming and
media services provider founded in April
2006. it is the world's largest music
streaming service provider and has over
381 million monthly active users which
also includes 172 million paid
subscribers the total number of
downloads on the Spotify app in the
Android store exceeded 1 billion in May
so millions of people listen to music
all day even I am hooked to music as an
analyst what's better than exploring and
quantifying data about music and drawing
valuable insights before I move ahead I
have a first question for you people
the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so which are
those two words please let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below I
would like to repeat the question again
the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so what are
those two words we would love to hear
from you so please put your answers in
the comment section below
now let's use Python libraries and
functions to analyze and visualize our
data set
first I'll show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so here is the first data set that we'll
be using for our demo and then I have my
second data set called Spotify features
which is essentially about the genres of
the different soundtracks
now these data sets have been downloaded
from kegel.com now the Links to the data
sets have been provided in the
description box please go ahead and
download them now let me just go ahead
and brief you about the columns that are
present in our first data set which is
about tracks we have a column A which is
ID this is the unique ID for each of the
songs then we have the name column which
is essentially the name of the song then
we have a column for popularity so the
popularity ranges from 0 to 100 then we
have duration in milliseconds this is
the duration of the track in
milliseconds next we have a column
called explicit now we are not bothered
about this column because we are not
going to use it in our analysis
then we have artists so the name of the
artist who has composed or sung the song
then we have ID of the artist then we
have a column for release date which is
basically the date on which the song was
released then we have a column for
danceability so this describes how
suitable a track is for dancing based on
a combination of musical elements such
as Tempo Rhythm stability beat strength
and overall regularity the value ranges
between 0 and 1.
next we have a column for energy so the
energy is a measure between 0.0 to 1.0
and represents a perceptual measure of
intensity and activity typically the
energetic tracks feel fast loud and
noisy higher the value the more
energetic is the sum
then we have a column for key so key is
the pitch notes or scale of song that
forms the basis of a song there are 12
Keys ranging from 0 to 11
moving ahead we have loudness so the
overall loudness of the track in
decibels it ranges from minus 60 to zero
decibels
then we have mode
so songs can be classified as major and
minor 1.0 represents major or one
represents major and 0 represents minor
next we have
speechiness so speechiness recognizes
the presence of spoken words in a track
more exclusive speech like the recording
example talk show audio book or poetry
the closer to 1.0 the attribute value
then we have a column for the cost
thickness
so a confidence measure of 0 to 1 of
whether the track is acoustic or not so
1.0 represents high confidence the track
is acoustic then we have other
information about
instrumental-ness
then we also have a column for
liveness so liveness detects the
presence of an audience in the recording
then we have a column for valence so
balance is a measure between 0.0 to 1.0
and describes the musical positiveness
conveyed by a track or a song
and finally we have The Columns for
Tempo and time signature
now
even in the second data set we have
almost the same columns just that we
have an additional column that is about
the genre of the songs present in the
data set cool now let's head over to our
Jupiter notebook and we'll start with
our analysis
okay so one more thing to remember our
data has information from
1922 onwards so all the songs from 1922
till 2021
cool
okay so I am on my Jupiter notebook so
you can see I have a few cells that have
already been filled up
so we'll start with our analysis first
of all let's go ahead and import the
necessary libraries so I'm importing
numpy pandas matplotlib and c bond for
my analysis and visualization I'll hit
shift enter to import the libraries all
right and in the next cell I am going to
load my data set using the pandas read
underscore CSV function I have my
location already
put here let me show you the location
where the data files or the data sets
are located so this is my location under
Chrome downloads I have a folder called
Spotify datasets
okay
so let's import and
set the first five rows in the data set
so for that I've used the head function
there you go so here you can see I have
my first five rows of information from
the data set and on the top you can see
the different columns you have ID name
popularity
artist
then we have the release date
danceability energy key loudness
liveliness or liveness
balance Tempo and other information
cool
now
let's check for null values in the data
set I'll just give a comment as
null values
every time when you download a data set
from an open repository there are
chances that the data set would contain
null values so it's better to check them
beforehand
so I'm going to use the use null
function present in the pandas Library
PD I'm using because I had imported
pandas SPD
so PD dot is null then I'm going to use
the variable name DF underscore tracks
because I imported my data set and
stored it in the variable DF underscore
tracks
so I have my data frame under
DF underscore tracks variable
and then I'll use the sum function to
check the total number of null values
present in the data set for each of the
columns if I run it there you go
so here you can see my name column has
missing values or null values and we
don't have any null values for the rest
of the columns
okay
now let's use the info method that will
give us the total number of rows and
columns in the data set and we'll also
check the data types and the memory
usage so I'll see
my data frame name that is DF underscore
tracks dot info
I run it you can see here
now if you mark there are total 5 lakh
601 names or
the names of the songs present in the
data set while the rest all have 5 lakhs
86 672 so clearly there are total 71
song names or soundtracks missing from a
data set
and Below you can see the data types we
have float integer and object and then
you can see the memory usage
cool
now before I move ahead with our next
analysis I have another question for you
which artist or musician has the most
number of followers on Spotify I repeat
number of followers on Spotify please
put your answer in the comment section
below we would be happy to hear from you
now let's
move ahead and do our first major
analysis in this demo we are going to
find the 10 least popular
songs present in the Spotify data set so
I'll create a variable called sorted
underscore DF that will be equal to my
data frame name that is DF underscore
tracks dot I am going to use the sort
underscore
values function and say
my column name is popularity
so I am going to sort the values based
on the
popularity and then say
ascending equal to true
since I want
only the least popular songs
and then
I'm going to say head of 10 which means
I want the top 10 least popular songs
now let's go ahead and print sorted
underscore dear if I run it you can see
we have the list of
10 least popular songs on Spotify you
can see that popularity is zero
and you can see the names of the songs
some of them are
songs which are not an English language
and you can see the artist names as well
cool
now moving ahead
let's see some descriptive statistics
for the numerical variables that are
present in our column so I'll say DF
underscore tracks dot describe
which is the function to get some
descriptive statistics and I'm going to
use the transpose function after that
if I run it there you go so we have the
statistics about count mean standard
deviation
minimum value 25th percentile 50th
percent 75th percentile and the maximum
value for these columns like popularity
duration in milliseconds then we have
energy key loudness mode
cool but if you see this
popularity column the minimum value is 0
and the maximum value is
100 and you can see the 15th percentile
is 27 which is essentially the median
you have the standard deviation as
18.37 then similarly you can check for
the other features as well
cool
now
we'll see the
then most popular songs which are
greater than 90. so we are going to
check for the top 10 songs with
popularity greater than 90 let me show
you how to do it so in this cell I am
going to create a new variable called
most popular
and I'll say DF underscore tracks dot
this time I am going to use the
query function that is part of pandas
Library again
I'll use the
column that is popularity and we'll set
the condition popularity should be
greater than 90 I'll give a comma and
say
in place equal to false because I don't
want to change my original data frame
and then I'll say
sort underscore
values
and I'm going to sort it based on
popularity
in
descending order so I'll say
ascending equal to false
and then let's
take only the
top 10 popular songs so I'll say most
popular new square brackets
use square brackets and
will then pass the slicing operator and
say colon 10
now if I run this there you go so here
you can see the 10 most popular songs
that is present in our Spotify data set
first we have peaches by
Justin Bieber
Daniel Caesar and given
then we also have a song name called
driver's license astronaut in the ocean
save your tears
we also have the business streets and
heartbreak anniversary
so these are the most popular songs that
are present in our data set based on
that
popularity you can see Peaches has the
highest popularity with 100.
all right now moving to the next cell
so here we are going to set the index to
be release date column in the main data
frame so I am setting my index using the
set underscore index function I have
passed in my column name as release date
and I'm saying increase equal to True
which means I want to change it in my
original data frame and then I'm
changing the value to date time format
and let's print the head of the
data set so you can see here we have
successfully changed our index now here
you can see instead of 0 1 2 3 we have
the release date column and the rest of
the columns are intact
cool
now let's move ahead
so suppose you want to check the artist
at the 18th Row in our data set you can
use the index location method for that
let me show you how to
filter only specific rows of information
from the data set I'll use my data frame
DF underscore tracks and using double
square brackets I'll say
by column name which is artists
and I'll use the index location method
and say let's say I want to check the
artist who is present
in the 18th Row in my data set so I'll
use ilock 18 if I run it the artist's
name is
with the voucher
cool
now let's move ahead we are going to
convert the duration in milliseconds to
just seconds so
if you see our data set we have a column
called duration in milliseconds so all
our songs are present in milliseconds
let's convert them into just seconds so
for that I'm using the Lambda function
and dividing the
values in
milliseconds by thousand so that they
get converted into just seconds
I have used in place equal to true so I
want to change it in my original data
frame let's run it and do the necessary
changes all right
now we'll print the head of the data set
just to check the duration column so
I'll say DF underscore tracks Dot
duration
dot head
if I run it there you go
so
you can see the values have now being
changed to just seconds
cool
I have the final quiz question for you
who has the most monthly listeners on
Spotify
please put your answers in the comment
section below we'd be glad to hear from
you
now coming to the next cell
so here we are going to create a first
visualization that is going to be a
correlation map
we are going to drop three unwanted
columns and those are key mode and
explicit and then we are going to apply
Pearson correlation method
now I have set my figure size to 14
comma 6 and then we are using the C bone
heat map function to create our
correlation map
I have put the variable that is
correlation underscore DF you can see
above we had created this and then I'm
setting annotation equal to true
so
this will write the data value in each
cell
I have set fmt equal to dot 1 G so this
is a string formatting code to use when
adding annotations then I have
set my vmin and V Max so these are the
values to Anchor the color map otherwise
they are inferred from the data and
other keyword arguments
cmap here stands for color map you can
just search for SNS cmap you will get
the documentation
so you can choose whichever
color palette or the color map you want
here I have used Inferno
and I have set my line bits and line
color finally I am giving a title to my
correlation map and I have set the
acetic labels let's go ahead and
run this to get our
first visualization
if I scroll down there you go we have
got a
nice
correlation map so here on the right
side you can see the scale it ranges
from -1 to plus 1 minus 1 means the
variables have least or negative
correlation while the values which are
above 0.0
means that the variables have a positive
correlation
now
here you can see there are
values like minus 0.7 for energy and
acousticness which means if the energy
is high the acousticness is really low
again for loudness and
say speakiness if the song is loud the
speechiness is low so there is negative
correlation but if you see
for energy and loudness there is really
high correlation between these two
variables you can see the value is 0.8
so if the song is loud this implies the
song has really high energy and vice
versa
now if you see for a few other variables
that is negative correlation between
acousticness and dance ability
there is negative correlation again
between
valence and the cost thickness similarly
there is positive correlation between
energy and balance which is 0.4
and even for danceability and balance
that is positive correlation which is
0.5
cool
so from the correlation heat map you can
note that acousticness appears to have a
strong negative correlation with energy
so if you see for acousticness and
energy there is a strong negative
correlation
and there is a moderately strong
positive relation between loudness and
popularity so if you see for popularity
and loudness the color is orange which
means it lies in this positive region
and there is also a moderately strong
positive relation between danceability
and balance so if you check for
danceability and balance here there is
a moderately strong positive correlation
all right
now let's move ahead we are going to
sample our data and take just 0.4
percent of the total data and will
create two regression plots using this
data so let me first sample my data so
I'll create a sample data frame
using my original data frame which is DF
underscore tracks and say
sample
I'm going to
use the int function and see 0.004
multiplied by the length of my original
data frame which is DF underscore
tracks
all right
now let's run this
and will print
the length of my
sample data frame
to run it you can see
point
four percent of
my total data set is
2346 rows
cool
now we are going to create a regression
plot between loudness and energy now in
our correlation map we saw there was a
positive correlation between loudness
and energy which was pointed let's plot
it in the form of a regression line so
I'll use
PLT Dot
figure
I'll set my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 6.
I'll say SNS Dot
regression plot so I'm using the
function called reg plot
and I'll use my data as
sample underscore
TF
give a comma
and say
in my y-axis I'll have my column
loudness
and in the x axis we'll have
energy
I'll give a
color to
my
data variable let's say the color is C
then I'll set my
title to
loudness
versus
energy
let's say correlation
all right
let's make sure everything is
fine
now
will run and see a result
there you go
so you can see here clearly
there is a very high positive
correlation between loudness and energy
on the y-axis we have loudness and on
the x axis we have energy and you can
see
all the data points or these songs are
in One Direction so if the energy
increases the loudness of this song also
increases and similarly if the loudness
of the song decreases your energy of the
song or the track also decreases so
there is a very high positive
correlation and you can see the
regression line here it has gone
and is increasing gradually
cool
now similarly I'll just copy this code
and we are going to see another
regression plot this time for two
different features
let's say we have
popularity in the
y-axis so I'll say popularity
and then in the x axis we have let's say
acousticness
thank you
I'll change the color to let's say B
which stands for blue
and
will set the title to
popularity
versus
I'll have
because thickness
correlation
just scroll down and we'll run it to see
the result
there you go
so I have the
different points for the songs and here
you can see the regression line is
downwards which means if the
acousticness of the song increases the
popularity decreases and similarly if
the popularity increases acousticness
decreases you can see
the downward trend of the regression
line
all right
now in the next cell we are going to
create a new column called ear from our
release date column
and I have changed this to date time
format let me just run it
cool
now after that
we are going to create a distribution
plot to visualize the total number of
songs in each year since 1922 that is
available on the Spotify streaming app
so I have used my c bond library and
dist plot function now one thing to
remember you need to update your c bond
library to
this version
if you haven't done it so use this
command pip install dash dash user C
burn and
the version
so here in the distribution plot
we are going to plot a histogram so I
have used kind equal to hist which
stands for histogram
let's run and see the result
okay so here you can see I have my
distribution plot so the plot tells us
that the
number of songs for each year in the
data set according to their release date
have increased in the recent years since
music became more accessible to people
globally with technological advancements
so earlier you can see there were very
few songs available in the
1920s later on the
number of songs increased rapidly and
now you can see we have a lot more songs
available for people to listen
cool
now
we are going to see the duration of
songs over the years for that again we
are going to create a bar plot so I'll
first create a variable called total
duration equal to DF underscore tracks
Dot
I'll use the duration column that we
created with seconds
and then
I am going to
set
my
figure Dimensions so I'll use figure
underscore
dims for Dimensions equal to
18 comma
7 after that I'll have my
trigger
access defined so I'll use the
matplotlib
sub plots function
and
I'll set the
figure size
equal to
my figure dimensions
and then
I'll say figure equal to SNS Dot I'll
use the
bar plot function
and say
my x axis to be
years
my Y axis will be
total
duration or total underscore Dr that we
created here
I'll set my Axis equal to ax
and then
I'll set error width
equal to
false
let's set the title for my plot as
title equal to
foreign
duration
and finally I'll say PLT dot text
I'll rotate it by
let's say 90 degrees
all right
let me just reach up once if everything
is fine and then we'll go ahead and run
it
my access error width title
okay let me just run it
will see the result in a moment
but if I scroll down
you can see we have the bar plot for the
different years and the duration of the
songs in seconds in the y axis so
earlier in the 1920s you can see the
duration of the
sounds well less and literate increased
around late
1930s and this remained consistent until
2010 where the duration was high but
after 2010 you can see the
duration of the songs have started
decreasing
now in the next cell
I am going to create a line plot to
analyze the average duration of the
songs over the years it is going to be
similar to
our bar plot does that now we are going
to visualize it in terms of a line
so I have my code ready
you can see here I've used my C bone
library and the line plot function in
the x-axis I have ears and in the y axis
I have total duration I have set my
title to year versus duration and I'm
rotating my
X labels by 60 degrees let's run it and
we'll see the output
there you go now if I scroll down you
can see we have a nice
line plot and on the x-axis you have the
use and on the y axis we have the
duration we can see that the songs from
1920s to
1960s have comparatively sorted duration
since most of the songs tended to be
more singing Beast rather than
instrument Beast
after 1960s you can see the duration of
the songs started increasing until I
would say 2010 and in the present day
the duration of the songs have started
declining since the attention span of
the average listener is also declining
all right now let's move to our second
data analysis project which is based on
genres of the songs so I am importing my
data set using the pandas read
underscore CSV function I have given my
location and here I have my data set
name followed by the
extension of the
type so this is a CSV data set let's go
ahead and run it
okay now
let's print the first five rows of the
data set
I have
stored my data set in a data frame
called DF underscore genre
I'll use the head function to get the
first five rows of information
I'll hit shift enter to run it there you
go
you can see here I have my Joiner column
artist name track name track ID
popularity the cost thickness
duration in milliseconds again
and we have the rest of the other
columns that we saw in our first data
set just one thing to note here key is
present in terms of c d e c minor F
minor
and not in terms of numbers between 0 to
11.
now we'll see
the duration of the songs for different
genres
for that I am going to create a bar plot
so I'll start with setting the title for
my plot as
duration of
the songs
in
different
genres
I'll use the
c bond Library
and
I'll set my
color palette to let's see
rocket
into the comma and say as C map
equal to true
this would be color palette
now
I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot in the y-axis I'll have
genre
and in the x axis I'll have
my duration column which is in
milliseconds so duration underscore MS
and then I pass my data frame using the
data argument
so I'll say data equal to DF dot John R
next
will
set the x labels so I'll say PLT dot X
label
let's see my X label is
duration in
milliseconds
and then
I'll see
PLT Dot
by label as donors
now let's go ahead and
run this
there you go so here you can see we have
the different genres on the y-axis and
on the x axis you have the duration in
milliseconds
and if you see the graph
for
classical genre and or
songs that belong to World genre the
duration of the songs are
more compared to
other genres now if you check for
children's music genre the duration is
less or the least
cool
and finally
we'll move to our
last demo where we'll see the top 5
genres by popularity
so I'll see
sns.set underscore
Style
I'll set my
style to
dark
grid which will be my background
and then I'll see PLT Dot
figure I'll set my
figure
size
to
10 comma 5
then I'll create a variable called
famous
since I want to take only the
most popular songs based on the genre so
I have created a variable called famous
and I'll pass my data frame name that is
DF underscore
genre
and I'll sort the values based on my
popularity column
so I'll see
popularity
and I want to
sort it in descending order so I'll say
ascending equal to
false
and I'll take the
first
10 values I'll tell you the reason why
I'm taking the first 10 values are not
5.
then I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot
and in the y axis I'll have
genre
in the x axis will have
popularity
and I'll keep a comma
and using the data argument I'll save my
data to be famous which is this variable
that we created
and then I'll set my
title
as
top five
Jonas
by popularity
all right
now the reason why I took head of 10 is
because there are a few genres which are
repetitive so if you see this we have
children's music appearing twice so
hence we have taken 10 instead of 5 let
me just go ahead and run it
there you go
so here if I scroll down you can see I
have my top 5 genres based on the
popularity so we have dance pop rap
hip-hop at reggaeton so these are the
five dollars which are most popular
based on the data that you have
collected
from Spotify
all right
hi everyone
welcome to this really interesting video
on data analysis of the 2021 World
happiness report using python
so today we will perform some
exploratory data analysis using python
libraries to analyze visualize and draw
insights from 2021 World happiness data
before I begin make sure to subscribe to
the simply launch Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
first let's understand what the world
happiness report 2021 is all about
the international happiness day is
celebrated every year since 2013 on 20th
of March to emphasize the importance of
happiness in the daily lives of people
so the United Nations sustainable
development Solutions Network published
the world happiness report on 19th of
March 2021 that ranks the world's 149
countries on how happy the citizens
perceive themselves to be based on
various indicators
the happiness study ranks the countries
on the basis of questions from the
Gallup World Poll
the results are then equated with other
factors such as GDP life expectancy
generosity Etc
this year it focused on the effects of
the covid-19 pandemic and how people all
over the world have managed to survive
and prosper
so using this 2021 data we will answer
critical questions such as the top 10
most corrupt countries
we will plot a graph to understand how
the happiness score is related to the
freedom of making Life Choices we look
at the life expectancy of 10 happiest
and 10 least happy Nations so these are
a few examples but we will explore more
about the data in detail in our demo
session
let's get started so first I'll show you
the data set we'll be using in this demo
so this data has been collected from
Kegel let me show you that
so this is the CSV data set that we have
downloaded from kegel.com so you can see
here World happiness report 2021
and
we will share the data set link in the
description of the video you can click
on the link to download the data set
now we have information about
149 countries you can see it here count
is 149 let me go to the top and I'll run
through the columns that are there in
this data set
so the First Column is the country name
so we have 149 different countries and
then we have something called as
Regional indicator we can call this as
just the region so you can see we have
different regions I've applied a filter
we have Central and Eastern Europe then
we have common wealth of independent
states so these include countries such
as Russia then we have East Asia Latin
America and Caribbean we also have South
Asia southeast Asia sub-Saharan Africa
Western Europe and other regions
I just cancel this and then we have the
happiness score column that has been
sorted in descending order
so we have Finland Denmark and
Switzerland who are the top three
happiest Nations now if I scroll down we
have countries like Rwanda Zimbabwe and
Afghanistan which are the least three
happy countries
no
there are a few columns that we won't be
using in our analysis so we will learn
how to exclude those columns and keep
only the relevant ones
so columns such as
standard error of ladder score
then we have
upper whiskers and lower whisker column
so we are going to ignore these columns
we are only concerned about
the GDP column which is this one then we
have the social support or the social
status column then we have the health
life expectancy
freedom to make Life Choices generosity
and perceptions of corruption and
there are a few other columns you can
see to the right and these columns are
not of our interest so we are going to
ignore them
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start by importing
all the necessary libraries for analysis
and data visualization
okay so I am on my Jupiter notebook so
first step I'll just
rename this notebook to let's say
happiness
report
data analysis
I'll click on rename all right now we'll
start by importing our libraries so
first Library I'm going to import is
numpy as NP
then I have
import
pandas as PD
then I'll import to data visualization
libraries C bone and matplotlib so I'll
say input
c bond as SNS and then
import
matplotlib
Dot
Pi plot
which is the module name as PLT
and
I'll say
percentage
matplotlib
inline
okay
now let me just go ahead and run this
all right
well now let's set the parameters that
control the general style of the plots
the style parameters control properties
like the color of the background and
whether a grid is enabled by default or
not
so for that I'll say sns.
set underscore
Style
I'll
give it as dark grid
next I'll say
PLT Dot
RC
params
which stands for runtime configuration
parameters I'm going to set my
font
size
to
let's say 15
then I'll say
PLT Dot
RC
params
now I am going to set the
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fixed size
let's say 10 comma 7
next
just copy this
paste it here
now we are going to set the
face color
so I'll see
figure Dot
face
color
I want to set it to peach color so I'm
going to pass in my RGB values for peach
I'm going to set it in terms of hex code
so for peach the value is f f
e
5 b and 4.
now let me run it okay
now it's time to load our data set
so for that I'll create a variable
called Data and
I'll use the
pandas Library
followed by the read underscore CSV
function because our data set that we
saw
is a CSP data set which is this one now
inside the parenthesis
I'll pass in the location of my
data file so I have my data here World
happiness report 2021 I'll just copy
this location and we'll
paste it here
and make sure the location is within
quotes
and you need to change it to
either forward slash or double backslash
so here I'm using
double backslash so let me just include
one more
backslash
and then I'm going to pass in the
file name which is
world
hyphen
happiness
hyphen report hyphen 2021
dot CSV which is the extension of the
file
now let me run it all right now to
display the first five rows of
information you can use the head
function
so I am writing data which is my
variable that holds the
data frame so data dot head
there you go
you can see here we have
printed the first five rows from the
data set you have the country name
Regional indicator happiness score
then we have information about the GDP
life expectancy generosity then we have
corruption data and these are some of
the columns that we are not bothered
about so we are going to drop these
columns from our analysis
now
we are going to do that so I'll create a
variable called Data columns which are
of our interest
so I am going to take only specific
columns I need the
country name so have
taken country name make sure the column
names are within single quotes So I have
my country name next I want the
second column which is
Regional indicator
I'll give a comma
we also need the
happiness score
next I need the
logged GDP per capita data
so I'll take that column
I'll say logged
GDP
per capita
give a comma my next column would be
social support
give a comma here
my next
column would be Health life expectancy
so I'll write
health
life expectancy
let's give another comma and we'll take
the next column as well which is freedom
to make life choices
so I'll write that column name freedom
to make
Life Choices
and finally
we'll take the
next two columns that is generosity and
perceptions of corruption So within
single quotes I'll say
generosity
give a comma and we're going to include
the final column which is of our
interest that is
perceptions of corruption
let me have a recheck
to ensure that I have put the column
names correctly otherwise it will show
an error
now let me go ahead and run this cell
I'll hit shift enter all right so we
have successfully
taken the columns that we'll be using
for an analysis
now I'm going to say data equal to
data I'll pass in my new variable that
is data underscore columns and I'm going
to copy all the data so I'll say dot
copy
let's run it
okay this should be data underscore
columns all right
now
let's rename all these columns we'll
make it more simpler and
easy to understand so I'll say
let's say my new
variable is Happy underscore DF which
stands for data frame equal to I'll say
data Dot we'll use the rename function
and using a dictionary we will
rename our columns so I have used a
curly bracket
I am going to pass in my
First Column which is country name I'll
just paste it here
then
I'm going to give a colon and again
Within single quotes I'll say country
underscore name so this is going to be
my new column name
and give a comma
we'll take the next
column which is regional indicator
I'll paste it here and give a colon and
the new column would be small r
Regional underscore
indicator
now similarly we'll do this for all the
remaining columns in the data set
okay now I have renamed all my columns
you can see it here
let's run it
now
we are going to display the head of the
data set again
so I'll say happy underscore DF dot add
there you go
so we have
only those columns that are of our
interest
so I have the country name Regional
indicator happiness score GDP social
support life expectancy
freedom to make Life Choices then I have
generosity and
perceptions of corruption
cool
now
we are going to check whether any of the
columns have
any null values so for that I will say
happy underscore DF
Dot
I'm going to use the is null function
I'll give another Dot and we are going
to find the sum
for each of the columns
you can see from the data we do not have
any
null values in any of the columns in the
data set
it is all zero
okay
now let's get started with our first
visualization that is
we'll create a plot between
happiness score and the GDP for
different regions
so for that I'll give a comment as
plot
between
happiness
and GDP
I'll just scroll down
cool
first I am going to set the
RC parameters so I'll say PLT Dot
RC params
within square brackets I'm going to give
my figure size so I'll say
figure Dot
fixed size
equal to let's say my figure size is 15
comma 7
I'll set the
title that is PLT dot title of my plot
to
let's say plot between
happiness score
and GDP
next
I'm going to say SNS Dot
let's create a scatter plot so I'll say
sns.scatter plot
I'm going to Define my x-axis on the
y-axis for the plot let's say in the x
axis we have
my data frame happy
underscore DF
Dot
this should be an underscore
I'll say
a column name as happiness underscore
score
give a comma
and in the y-axis we'll have
my data frame name that is Happy
underscore DF Dot
will have the GDP column that is
logged underscore GDP
underscore per underscore capital
let's give a comma and we'll pass in Hue
for
the color
let's say for Hue I'm going to use the
original
column or the regional indicator column
so I'll say
happy underscore DF
Dot
Regional underscore indicator
and then I am going to give this size of
the dots as let's say 200
then I'll give a semicolon
come to the next line
I'll say PLT dot let me just scroll down
we are going to define the legend so
I'll say PLT Dot Legend
and in Legend we'll have
the location let's say I want to put the
legend at upper left
corner so I'll say loc which is for
location equal to upper left
give a comma and then see
font size of my Legend let's say B10
make sure this is within quotes
then I'm going to pass my x-axis labels
and the y-axis labels
so I'll say plt.x label
let's see the X label is
happiness score
and my by label is
GDP per capita so I'll say PLT dot y
label
within single quotes I'll say GDP per
capital
there's an error here this should be
plot all right so I have
written my code to create a scatter plot
let's run it and see the result
there is some error here
okay this should be
Regional
indicator and not in the K3 there's a
spelling mistake let's run it again
all right
so here you can see we have a nice
scatter plot on the top you can see we
have the title of the plot that is plot
between happiness score and GDP on the
x-axis we have the happiness score from
0 to 8
and above
and on the y axis you have the GDP per
capita
and if you see here
in this region we have
countries from
Western Europe which have the
highest happiness score and the GDP per
capita is also the highest
around this region you can see here
which is for green and in the legend you
can see green is for sub-Saharan Africa
so all these countries have
low happiness score and even the GDP per
capita is also low
and if you see the
countries for
Latin America and Caribbean you see a
lot of the values lie here so they are
all within the range of 5.52
7 in happiness score
and even the GDP per capita is more than
9 for most of them
now even the happiness score is high for
the countries that line the North
America and Enz region and even that GDP
per capita is also the highest I can
name a few countries such as Australia
New Zealand we have Canada and
United States of America which belong to
the North America and ANC region cool
now there is one country which you see
here this seems to be like an outlier
which means that this is the country
which has the lowest happiness score and
even the GDP per capita is also low but
it is not the lowest because you can see
here there are a few countries up here
from the sub-Saharan Africa which have
the lowest GDP per capita but the
happiness score is higher than this
value or this country so we can assume
that this country is Afghanistan which
has the lowest happiness score as per
the 2021 happiness report data
cool
now we'll plot a pi plot to understand
the GDP by region so by this we can know
which region has the highest percentage
contribution to the world's GDP as per
our data
for that
I'll create a variable GDP underscore
region
equal to
we'll use our data frame that is Happy
underscore DF
dot I'm going to use the
Group by function
and
after that
I'm going to use my
column that is
region
so we have named the column as Regional
underscore indicator so I'm going to
group it by this region column
and I'm going to sum the values of GDP
so I'm going to use the logged
underscore GDP underscore per capita
column
and after that I am going to use the sum
function
and let me just print GDP underscore
region
you can see it here we have the
sum of all the countries
for different
regions and their GDP all total
now this data we are going to plot it in
the form of a pi plot
so I'll see
GDP underscore region
Dot
plot
Dot pi
we are going to plot it in terms of
percentage so I am going to use a
parameter called
Auto PCT
equal to then I am going to pass in my
format
so I'll say percentage 1.1
f
percentage percentage
then I'll say PLT Dot
title
let's see the title of my Pi plot is
going to be GDP by
region
and I'll say PLT Dot
by label
which is going to be blank
let's run it
okay
so here you can see
we have the each background at the back
because we had
assigned
a peach
face color you can see it here
so for the first
scatter plot also we had the peach color
at the back
and now you can see
we have sub-Saharan Africa contributing
20.7 percent to the world's GDP the
reason being we have
around 34 countries in the sub-Saharan
Africa
and
we have the Western European countries
contributing to 16.2 percent of the GDP
to
check the least we have North American
ANC region because we only have four
countries America Australia Canada and
New Zealand so hence they are
contributing only 3.1 percent to the
world's GDP
okay now moving ahead
let's find the total number of countries
in each region so for this we are going
to use the group by function that is
part of the pandash library and we'll
count the total number of countries in
each region
so I'll just give a comment
as
total countries
all right just scroll down
so I'll create a variable called total
underscore country
I am going to use my data frame that is
Happy underscore DF dot I'm going to use
the
Group by function
I'll group
the values based on the region column So
within single quotes I'll see
Regional underscore
indicator
and then
I'm going to
find the total count of country name so
I'm using the column country underscore
name
and after that I'll just use dot count
now let's go ahead and
print my variable that is
total underscore country
all right now let me hit shift enter
okay so here you can see
all right so for sub-Saharan Africa
there are total 36 countries and not 34
as I mentioned earlier so hence you can
see because it has the highest number of
countries it is contributing the most to
the world's GDP that is 20.7 percent
then we have the least number of
countries in North America and ANC that
is only four we have six countries in
East Asia and then we have 20 countries
in Latin America and Caribbean 12
countries it Commonwealth of independent
states then we have 17 countries in
Central and Eastern Europe
cool now
I'm going to show you how to create a
correlation map so that we can see the
relationship that exists between each of
the variables that are present in our
data set I'll just run through the code
and we'll see the output
okay so here I have my code written for
the correlation map that I want to
create so first of all I am going to
compute the correlation Matrix so I have
used the Corr function which stands for
correlation and the method I am going to
use is Pearson method now here I have a
Wikipedia page opened for Pearson
correlation coefficient so this is a
nice article where you can understand
what the person correlation is all about
and then I am going to set up the
matplotlib figures so I have used the
subplots function and I have given the
figure size as 10 comma 5. and after
that we are going to draw the
heat map with the mask so I'm using the
heat map function present in the c bond
library and then I have passed in my
variable that is cor which essentially
stands for correlation
and then I have used mask which is a
Boolean array or it can be a data frame
and it is an optional parameter if it is
passed the data will not be shown in
cells where the mask is true
and the cells with missing values are
automatically masked after that I have
used the
cmap parameter which stands for color
map so you can customize the colors in
your heat map and I'm going to create a
heat map which is in square shape so I
have said Square equal to true and the
axis I am going to pass it as ax which I
have defined here so this is the
matplotlib axis and it is optional so
axis in which you want to draw the plot
otherwise you can use the current active
access
now let me just go ahead and run this
and we'll see the heat map
there you go
so if I scroll down here we have the
correlation Matrix and since I had given
my cmap as blue
and here you can see it is mostly blue
and we have the scale here
now
I'll tell you how to read this
correlation Matrix so wherever the cells
are in blue or dark blue color this
means that the variables have very high
correlation and all these cells where
you see light blue color or grayish and
white color
this indicates that the variables have
very low correlation for example there
is very low or
almost negative correlation between
happiness score and perceptions of
corruption so obviously if the citizens
of a country feel that there is a lot of
corruption in the country that happiness
score would obviously be less or low
and if you see there is also low
correlation between happiness score and
generosity there is
then low correlation between
Health life expectancy and perceptions
of corruption
and if you see these places
there is really high correlation between
the happiness score and GDP per capita
again for social support also there is
very high correlation
now if you see even for
social support and healthy life
expectancy there is very high
correlation but there is
low correlation between
making life choices and generosity
and there is
negative correlation between corruption
and freedom of making life choices you
can see it is almost white color which
means it falls around this region so
negative correlation
similarly for
logged GDP per capita and
corruption that is
negative correlation all right
okay now we are going to visualize a bar
plot that will tell us the corruption in
different regions so I'll just give a
comment
corruption in
regions
let me just scroll down okay
so I'll create a variable called
corruption
which will be equal to
my
data frame that is Happy underscore DF
now first of all I'm going to use the
group by function to group all my
regions so I'll say Regional underscore
indicator Which is my
column name present in the data set and
after this I am going to find the
average of the corruption that is
perceptions of corruption so I am going
to pass in my
variable name that is
perceptions of
corruption
and I'm going to use the mean function
to find the average corruption in each
of these regions
now let me just go ahead and print my
variable that is corruption
if I run it you can see here
I have the values for the different
regions and from here you can see that
Central and Eastern Europe has the
highest perceptions of corruption as per
the
questions answered in the poll
and if you see the table
we have Western Europe
and the North America region with the
least perceptions of corruption now we
are going to visualize this using a bar
plot now so first of all I'll
set my
parameters by giving the
figure size
I'll say
fig
size
it's rather figure dot fixed size
I'll just add figure here
okay
and now let's see
I'll assign it as 12 comma 8.
now I'll give a title to my plot so I'll
say PLT dot title
and my title of the plot is going to be
perception of
corruption
in
various
regions
all right
then I am going to Define my X label
so I'll say x label will be
regions
and
we'll set the font size of the X label
to let's say 13
or let it be 15
then we are going to set the
y label
in violable I'll have
corruption index
as the label name
again we are going to set the font size
to 15
now I'm going to use
X ticks
parameter
since I want to
rotate the axis labels in the x axis by
30 degrees so I'll say rotation
equal to 30
and I'll say h a which stands for
horizontal alignment equal to right
make sure this right should be within
single quotes
and finally I'll say PLT dot bar because
I'm going to plot a
bar graph
I'll say corruption
dot index
comma
and then I'll say
corruption
Dot
perceptions of
corruption which is my column name
all right so I have my code ready for
the bar plot now let me just go ahead
and
print
the bar plot
make sure everything is correct I'll
just hit shift enter
okay there is one mistake here it says
okay this should be X ticks and not X
tick
let me run it again there you go
so if I scroll down
on the top you have the
title which is perception of corruption
in various regions on the
x-axis you have the regions label on the
y-axis you have the corruption index and
if you see this
as per our table that we created
we have least corruption in North
America and ANZ region then we have the
next least corruption in Western Europe
but we have the highest corruption in
Central and Eastern Europe as per that
citizens perception similarly we have
the
second and third highest corruption in
Latin America and Caribbean as well as
South Asia
cool
now moving ahead
I'm going to show you how you can find
the life expectancy of the top 10
happiest countries and bottom 10 happy
countries so for that I am going to run
you through the code and we'll see the
visualization side by side
okay so I have my code written in these
two cells so first I am going to find
out the top 10
happiest countries and then I am going
to find the bottom 10 happiest countries
so for that I'm using the head function
and I have passed in 10 since I want the
top 10 country names and to get the
bottom 10 countries as per their
happiness score I am using the tail
function so let me just run it so we
have saved the result in two variables
top underscore 10 and bottom underscore
10. and two
create the bar plots we are using
two different
codes so here you can see I have set my
figure size and access and then I have
my X label as
country name
after that I am setting my
title of the bar plot to top 10 happiest
countries life expectancy I've used my
x-tick labels and I'm rotating it by 45
degrees and I have my horizontal
alignment as right
you can see it here we have used the bar
plot function I have the x-axis as
country name and y-axis as healthy life
expectancy column and I have set my Axis
then
um using the X labels and Y labels as
country name and life expectancy and
similarly I have my bar plot for
the bottom 10 least happy countries life
expectancy
let's just run it and we'll see the
result
there you go
if I scroll down you can see we have
two different bar plots the first one is
for the 10 happiest countries and then
we have the bottom 10 least happy
countries
so if you see
on an average the top 10 happiest
countries life expectancy is above 70
years so if you are from one of these
countries you are expected to live
for more than 70 years now if you check
the bottom 10 least happy countries you
see here
Lesotho has less than 50
life expectancy age and most of them are
less than
60 years so if you are from one of the
top 10 happiest countries you are
expected to live
10 years more than these countries that
line the bottom 10 region
cool
now moving ahead
all right so now we are going to see the
plot between freedom to make life
choices and the happiness score for this
I am going to use a scatter plot so
I'll first Define my figure size so I'll
say PLT Dot
RC p a r a m s which stands for
parameters
I am going to pass in my
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fig size
equal to
let's say 15 comma 7
then using the C bone library and the
scatter plot function
will pass in the
x axis let's say the x axis is
my data frame name happy underscore DF
and
I'll have the freedom to make life
choices in the x-axis
so the column name is freedom underscore
2 underscore make
underscore life
and choices
and give a comma and we'll pass in the
y-axis again I am going to use my
data frame name
Dot and I'll have the happiness score
I'm also going to
pass in a hue parameter
to differentiate
the different regions
so I'll say DF Dot
Regional underscore indicator
and I'll give the size of the dots
or the Bubbles as let's say 200
now I'll see
PLT Dot
Legend
I'll place the legend
at upper left corner so I am giving the
location which is loc equal to
upper left
and
font size
Let It Be
12.
I'll say PLT Dot
X label
as
freedom to make life
choices
and my y label
would be happiness score
all right
now we have the code written for the
scatter plot that I want to create let
me just run it
there you go
so here we have the legend for the
different regions and we have the
different colors for each of these
regions
and you can see here
I have
on the x-axis freedom to make life
choices and on the y-axis we have the
happiness core
so you can see it very clearly
for the countries that line the Western
Europe region the blue dots
the freedom to make life's choices is
more and so is the happiness score
then if you see
the values the
green region which is for Middle East
and North Africa the freedom to make
life's choices is
lower and hence the happiness score is
also low and for all these countries
that are part of the sub-Saharan Africa
some of them have
decent
score for freedom to make life's choices
but the happiness score is low again
now if you focus on the
pink dots which is for the Southeast
Asian countries the happiness core is
comparatively lower but the
freedom to make life's choices is more
than
0.8
cool and again we have one data point
which is
lying at the bottom we can assume this
is Afghanistan so in Afghanistan the
freedom to make life's choices is very
low and even the happiness score is
really low
cool
now moving to our next analysis
we are going to see the top 10 most
corrupt countries
so first I am going to sort the
perceptions of corruption column and
find out the top 10 countries in the
list
so for that I'm going to create a
variable called country
I'll have my data frame name that is
Happy underscore DF dot sort underscore
values
by
I'm going to sort by
column that is
perceptions
of
corruption
Dot
head
and I want to find the top 10 most
corrupt countries as per the
Pole
and then
I'm going to
pass in the figure size so I'll say PLT
dot RC
params
and then I'm going to set the
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fixed size
make sure there is no spelling mistake
let's say the figure size is 12 comma 6.
I'll pass in the title so I'll say PLT
Dot
title let's say the title of my plot is
going to be
countries
with
most
perception of
corruption
after that I'll say PLT Dot
X label
in the X label I'll have country and
I'll set the
font size to
then I'll say PLT Dot
y label
in y label I'll have the
corruption
index
next
I'll
pass in the font size for the buy label
again it is going to be 13
now I'll say PLT dot X
I am going to
rotate it by 30.
and I'll say horizontal alignment equal
to
right
and then
I'll have my
bar function or the bar plot function so
I'll say PLT dot bar
I'm going to pass in country Dot
country
underscore name
and then we'll have my variable country
Dot
the column name that is
perceptions of
corruption
all right
now if I run it
you can see here
so these are the countries with the
least perceptions of corruption so
Singapore has the
lowest corruption index
and then we have Rwanda Denmark Finland
now if you want to see the countries
with the
highest perceptions of corruption you
need to change this head to
deal of 10 since we are sorting it in
ascending order so we would want to know
the bottom 10 countries if I run it
there you go so these are the countries
with the most perception of corruption
you have Slovakia Lesotho
Kosovo there's Ukraine Afghanistan
Bulgaria Romania and Croatia all of
these countries have a corruption index
of more than
0.85
cool now coming to the final section of
this interesting video on happiness
report data analysis for 2021 I want to
visualize a scatter plot that will tell
us how the corruption varies in terms of
Happiness core
so I'll just say
a comment as corruption versus
happiness
okay
so first of all I'll set my
figure size so I'll say PLT Dot
RC
params
within single quotes I'll give the
figure size
as
15 comma 7.
then I'm going to use the scatter plot
function that is part of the c bond
Library
in the x-axis I'll have my
column that is
corruption or rather we'll have the
happiness score in the x axis so I'll
say happy underscore DF Dot
column name that is happiness score
let me give a comma and in the y-axis
we'll have
corruption column so I'll say happy
underscore DF Dot
perceptions of
corruption
and then
in Hue we'll have the region that is
Regional underscore indicator so I'll
say happy underscore DF Dot
Regional
indicator
and I'm going to give the size of the
dots so I'll say s equal to 200
foreign
PLT Dot
Legend
I'm going to
put it at
lower left corner this time so I am
giving my location as
lower left
and
the font size of the Legend I Want Is
14.
after that I'll just say PLT Dot
X label
as
corruption and
PLT Dot
y label
as
happiness score
you know this should rather be the
opposite since in the x axis we have
taken happiness score
so we'll
put the happiness score label in X and
I'll have corruption in y
all right
so I have my scatter plot
code ready let me just run it
there you go
so here you can see on the lower left I
have the different regions and on the x
axis I have the happiness score on the y
axis I have the corruption index now you
can see the general Trend as per the
scatter plot that the countries with
greater happiness score have lower
corruption index so you can see these
countries which are from the Western
European regions have
highest happiness score and the
corruption is also really low so all
these blue countries we can name a few
Finland we have Sweden we have Belgium
France Netherland lying in these regions
we also have a few countries from North
America and ENC which are essentially
Australia then we also have Canada U.S
and New Zealand
okay now if you focus on these
green region this region
now these are the countries from the sub
Saharan Africa and most of the countries
from these regions have a very low or
less than five happiness score but the
corruption is also really high you can
see here they have almost more than 0.7
the corruption index
now
you also have a country here which is
from the
southeast Asia we would like to give you
a task it would be really great if you
can tell us in the comments section
which country is this
it has more than six happiness score but
the corruption index is really low Which
is less than
0.2
now if you consider
Middle East and North African regions
the
darker green countries here also if you
see the happiness score is less than 5
and the corruption index is also High
now there are a few countries the
Commonwealth of independent states for
example
countries such as Uzbekistan then you
also have Kazakhstan we have Russia
Armenia belonging to these
gray color dots you also have Georgia
and Ukraine as part of Commonwealth of
independent states so here you see the
corruption is below
0.6 for these countries and the
happiness score is more than 5
all right so with that we have come to
the end of this demo session on world
happiness report 2021 data analysis
using python
hello everyone
welcome to this exciting video on
Olympics data set analysis using python
by simply learn
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where I'll give
you a brief about the history of
Olympics and throw some light into the
recently held Tokyo Olympics
but we'll focus more on using Olympics
data set that is available on Kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in Python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion I'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the Olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin
the Olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet it is held
every four years
the first modern Olympics took place in
Athens Greece in 1896. as per National
Geographic the original Olympics took
place in 776 BC
so they began as part of an ancient
Greek festival which celebrated Jews the
Greek god of sky and weather
the Rings in the Olympics logo represent
the five continents Europe Africa Asia
the Americas and Oceania
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
Summer Olympics took place in the same
year but now they alternate every two
years
before I move on here is an interesting
question for you only two people have
ever won gold medals at both the summer
and the Winter Olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the Summer Olympics in Tokyo began on
the 23rd of July and recently concluded
on the 8th of August
we got to witness some Thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well winning and losing
are pardon parcel of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see This Global event happened this
year Following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our Olympic fever High let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past Olympics data and answer
specific questions in this video we'll
be using specific python libraries such
as numpy pandas macplotlip and c-bond to
make sense of our data and extract
meaningful information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before I show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis I have
another general question for you
which is the first Olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
Olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the ear and the city name where the
Olympics was held in the comments
section of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video
so here you can see I have my Olympics
data set folder that has two data sets
these are CSV files one is called the
athlete underscore events and the other
one is called NOC underscore regions so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from Kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now I'll show you the data sets so this
is my first data set you can see on the
top athlete underscore events so I have
around 15 columns you can see the count
here and there are nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use the other data set we are
going
to use in this demo is called NOC
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is NOC stands for National Olympic
Committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the Olympic Committee
you have the region name so afg is for
Afghanistan you have elb for albinia elg
for Algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the region for example here
antiqua is actually antiqua and Barbuda
all right
let's move to the first data set that I
showed you this is a primary data set
for our demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains nearly 2 lakhs 71
116 rows of information and there are 15
columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
Olympic event
so here ID is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or F for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms we have the team
name these are the country names you
have China Denmark Netherland there are
around 200 country names
then we have the NOC as I said NOC is a
three letter code that stands for
National Olympic Committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the Winter
Olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the ear column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or Winter Olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host City
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball Judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for Speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal be it gold
silver branch and any means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets now let's get
started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so I'll take you to my Jupiter
notebook right away
I have opened it on Chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here Olympics data set
analysis I have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use numpy pandas
matplotlibbon c-bond let me hit shift
enter to import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the data
sets
using pandas read underscore CSV
function
so
I'll create a variable called athletes
I'll say equal to
PD dot I'll use the read underscore CSV
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so I'll copy this location
and here I'll paste make sure this is
within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
I'll give another forward slash and
after that I'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
events
dot CSV
I'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will load the second data
set I'll create another variable called
regions
so it will have my data frame
I'll use the same function PD dot read
underscore CSV
I'll just copy this
file path till here
we paste it
and
I'll give my second file name which is
NOC underscore
regions dot CSV you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second word is NOC underscore
regions
okay I'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error I
think this is Regions
cool
now moving ahead let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
I'll use the head function for that
I'll see
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set athletes you can see
here
from 0 to 4 you have 5 rows of
information the ID name sex or the
gender each height feet
if I go to the right you have games your
season sport event and medal
now let's see the
second data set that we
imported or loaded I'll see regions dot
head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay I have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have NOC region and some
notes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
I'll create a variable
called athletes underscore TF
then
I'll use my first variable which is
athletes
I'll say dot merge which is my function
name
I'm going to merge
the regions data frame
I'll use the how parameter
in how I'll give my value as I want to
do a left join
and my common column in both the
datasets is actually NOC
so I'm going to use
the NOC column as my common column to
merge both the data sets now let's go
ahead and
print the
merged data frame I'll say athletes
underscore DF dot head let's run it
there you go
so if you see clearly if I move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
First Data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last columns that we just added
now start with the lowercase letter so
we'll use
the rename function to
meet the column names consistent
but before that
let's
see the shape of the data frame so I'll
print the shape of the data frame to
know the total number of rows and
columns I'll say
athletes if I hit tab
you will see it will give me
The Prompt I'll select athletes
underscore DF
I'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had 15
columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes 17
now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so I'll show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF
dot I'll use the rename function
and then I'll say
columns
equal to
I'll use curly braces
My First Column that is region I want to
change it to
a region but the r should be Capital now
or uppercase
give a comma
and then see
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes I want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
I'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
we'll give a comma here and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
and this athletes underscore DF data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function I'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
I'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types non-null values and
memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so I'll write
athletes underscore DF dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have 2 lakhs
7116 rows or entries
then you have the
different column names and
you see it says non-null and the data
type of the column below you can see
some information about the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types so let me show
you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical summary
I'll just write describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if I scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns so
here you can see we have the total count
the mean of each of these columns you
have the standard deviation the minimum
and maximum value and then we have the
25th percentile the 15th percentile and
the 75th percentile value of the columns
ID age height weight and here
all right now one thing to notice here
is if you see the ear column the minimum
year is
1896 so this is when
Olympics started and until recently
the Rio Olympics that was held in 2016.
all right now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in The Columns of the
data set
so first I am going to create
a variable called
Nan values
give equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF and the function
to check is I'll say is any
I'll create another
variable called Nan underscore
columns
and here I'll use the any function I'll
say Nan underscore this
variable which is underscore values
dot I'll see any
and I'll print my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
Boolean values so if there are any null
or any n or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you Mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
each height weight middle region and
notes columns that have
missing values so hence it has given us
true the rest of the columns do not have
any any n or missing values hence they
are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so I'll say
athletes
underscore DF dot I'll use the function
is null and again I'll use this sum
function
okay this should be is null
if I run it you can see it here
so on each column has 9474
rows where we have null values
then we have some null values for the
height column as well for the weight
column so these are the total number of
rows where we don't have any information
regarding each height weight or region
notes this middle is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in Olympics
don't win any medals so for them the
value is an a now before I move ahead
I have a question for you people so the
question is I want you to print the
column names containing null values or
missing values in the form of a list
so please answer this question and put
it in the comment section of the video
we would be happy to know your approach
so the question I'll repeat it again I
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list so
basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had null values I want
you to print these six columns in the
form of a list
all right now moving ahead now let's see
the data for specific countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the Olympic
Games from the beginning for India
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF Dot
we'll use the query function
and then
I'll say team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value I'll give us India
now let's display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from India if I run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within single quote I'll just delete
this single code from here and we'll add
it in the end
now let's run it there you go
so here you can see we have
the top five rows of
the athletes who are from India you can
see here the region is India you can see
the nocs India the team is India and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete the sex each so for
each you have some missing values you
have the wheat team here and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for Japan
let me just copy the
above code
I'll paste it here and instead of India
I'll say
Japan
I'll run it there you go so if you see
here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from Japan
all right
now moving ahead now I want to know the
top 10 countries who have participated
since the Inception of Olympics in 1896.
so for that I'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
let's say equal to
I'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore TF
I'll say dot team
then I'll use the function
value underscore
counts
I'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just Mark the way in which I'm writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will throw you an error
I want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it I'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be short underscore
values and not value
let's run it again there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in Olympics since
1896 you have United States then we have
France so these are the number of
participants who have taken part since
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada Japan
Sweden
we also have Australia and Hungary
I'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph so I am trying to
create a bar plot to plot the top 10
countries who have participated in
Olympics so here I'm using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now I'll tell you about this PLT X ticks
means just wait for a while
I have given a title to my plot saying
overall participation by country
and then
using the c bond library and the bar
plot function I am plotting the X and
the
y-axis so my x axis has top
I should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis I'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then I'm using
a color palette called set 2.
let's run it
there you go so if I scroll down you can
see here we have a nice bar plot this is
a vertical bar plot and here you can see
the bars which represent the different
country names first we have United
States which has the highest
participation since the beginning of the
Olympics then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes so for this we are going to
create a histogram
I'll be using the matplotlab library
specifically for this visualization
so I'll say PLT dot figure
will give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6.
I'll say
PLT
Dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want I'll see
each
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the X labels I'll
say PLT Dot
X label
this will have each
then we'll see PLT Dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next I'm going to use the hist function
so I'll say plt.hist
and I'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes underscore DF
Dot
each
which is my column name
comma
I am going to pass in the
bins
for that I am going to use the NP dot
e-range function so MP is for numpy
and inside this I'll say 10 comma
80 comma 2.
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2.
comma
I'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins I
want my color to be orange
and then
I'll use
The Edge color to separate the bins
LC Edge color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color I want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be Edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the
each of the athletes you can see the
title is distribution of the athletes on
the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x axis we have the
age values ranging from 10 to 80 with a
size of
and if you see this we have most number
of athletes
who have each between
20 to 30 you can see here so early 20s
we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the Olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
Beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a few athletes even closer to 60
also and similarly we have a few
athletes who are under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so are all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
Olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter Olympic Games
just to give you a heads up the Winter
Olympic Games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here I have my variable name winter
underscore Sports so I'm extracting
for season equal to equal to Winter and
I am going to display only the unique
values now let me run this cell
okay so we can see here these are the
different winter sports that are
held during the winter Olympics now
similarly let's see for
Summer Olympics so what I'm going to do
here is I'll just copy this cell of code
and we'll edit the
variables I'll say summer
underscore Sports
athletes underscore DF Remains the Same
here season will change it to
summer
.sport dot uniquely means the same and
here I'll say summer underscore Sports
this should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
mode number of Olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
Winter Olympics
so these are the sports that have played
on snow and ice and these are the sports
that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 Rio Olympics
all right
so I'll see
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
I'll use my
data frame that is athletes underscore
DF Dot
my variable name that is sex Dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the Inception of Olympics
we have more number of male participants
than female participants
now here in this current cell you can
see we are trying to plot a pie chart
for male and female athletes so I have
given my figure size then I have my
title as gender distribution I am using
the Mac plot Live library and the Pi
function I am using the variable gender
counts that we used here
then I am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts.index now I am using
this Auto PCT the auto PCT parameter
enables you to display the percent value
using python string formatting so this
is my string formatting that I have used
and I'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and I am also
giving Shadow to my pie chart so I have
written Shadow equal to True let's run
it all right so you can see here this is
my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the male and female
participation
so for me it is 72.5 percent of female
so far it is
27.5 percent as per the data set that we
have
we can change this start angle to let's
say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we are going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so I'll use my
data frame athletes underscore DF Dot
and then my column that is Middle I'll
say dot value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are very much similar
to each other the numbers are pretty
much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
Olympics
so I'll create a variable called female
underscore
participants
I'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
DF
using square brackets
I'll see
athletes
underscore DF Dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
I'll use ampersand
I'll say
just copy this
paste it here
LC Dot season
equal to equal to we'll check for Summer
Olympics
and I want to extract only
the gender column so here it is X comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
I'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
I'll just copy this
paste it here
and then I'll use the group by function
say group Bhai which is part of the
pandas Library
I'll see here
and then I want to find the count
I'll reset the index
say reset underscore index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is I am
trying to filter my data only for the
female athletes for Summer Olympics and
here I am printing
the participation based on each year so
I'm finding out the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result there you go
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the Olympics
you can see it here for the Beijing
Olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
London Olympics we had
5815 Olympics similarly for the 2016 Rio
Olympics we had
more participation than the London
Olympics so 6223
women athletes that participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your data for female athletes so
I'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is Summer Olympics let me just run it I
have stored it in a variable called
women Olympics
now
here I am trying to find a
count plot or I am trying to create a
count plot using my c-bond SNS Library
I have set my style to dark grid then my
figure size I have given as 20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x-axis
as year
the data is women Olympics and Palette
I'm using as spectral and then I have
given a title women participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if I scroll down you can
see on the top I have the title for my
account plot which says women
participation and on the y-axis I have
the count and at the bottom you can see
the different year values from 1900 till
2000 and
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend which
says plot for female athletes over time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually the women participation has
increased in Olympics since
its Inception there was a slight
decrease here this is around
1950s and again you can see here there's
a decrease with the women participation
in 1980 but since then since 1980 there
has been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section of
our analysis
we are going to filter the data to see
the details of the athletes who have won
gold medals
so I'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to I'll use my
data frame as athletes underscore DF
and
within parenthesis I'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
DF Dot
I'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
I am going to say
gold medals dot head
let's run it there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won a gold medal you can see all the
records have middle as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis so here
I want to take only the values that are
different from any n so I'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that I have set gold
medals each
let me just run it cool
now I want to see
the athletes who have secured a gold
medal beyond the age of 60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of age
having won a gold medal
so here I'm going to say
gold medals
I'll use my
column as ID
and then
I'll use
my variable gold medals
and then
I'll say each
should be
greater than
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
I'll run it and we'll see the result so
there are total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so I'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
I'll use the
same variable name gold medals
I'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
I'll give my
condition each
greater than 60.
now let's go ahead and we'll print
the variable sporting event
if I run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called Rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so I'll say PLT Dot
figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
I'll say PLT Dot
we'll use the
tight layout
sit tight underscore layout
then I'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore event
then I'll say PLT Dot
title
I'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if I scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot I have my title
gold medals for athletes over 60 years
and since for archery we had three
players who secured a gold medal having
an each more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one Rogue is one and
shooting we had
One Medal
all right
now we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
I'll say
gold
medals
Dot we'll use the
region column
and
followed by that I'll use the
value underscore counts function and
I'll reset the index
with name
equal to I'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
USC
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have Russia Germany UK
and then we have Italy
cool
now in this cell I am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that I got above
so I've used my labels my titles I'm
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond Library I have my
x-axis my y-axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay and we'll run it
if I scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that I had used which is a rocket
and you can see USA has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
Russia Germany UK Italy and France now
we also have included France here which
was not present in this table the reason
being I have used head as six so it'll
give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
Olympic event that is present in our
data set I'm talking about the 2016 Rio
Summer Olympics
so first of all I'll create a variable
called Max ear
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore DF
my column name here and I'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my Max here
I'll just show you the output you can
see here my Macs here present in the
data set is 2016. the Rio Olympics
next
we will create another variable called
team underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give
parenthesis and then see
athletes underscore TF Dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my output that is Max here
which is actually 2016.
and then I'll say
ampersand
I'll just copy this
will paste it here
this time I'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
I'll say dot team
then I'll say team underscore names Dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
countries
let me run this
there you go
so in Geo Olympics
United States secured the
most number of gold medals now the
reason this is 137 is we have also
counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly Great Britain had 64 gold
medals in total
Russia 50 we have Brazil 34 Argentina 21
France 20 and Japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot I'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also I'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it and you can see here we
have a nice
horizontal bar plot so we have United
States at the top Great Britain Russia
Germany China Brazil so here I am
displaying the top 20 Nations since I
have used head as 20
so these are the top 20 Nations who
secured the most number of gold medals
in the Rio Olympics
all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal now if you
had noticed here are
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
so for that I'll create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF
then
I'll give my
let's make it DF
I'll give my condition
let me just copy this
I'll paste it here
and then
I'll give my condition height
and use the
not null
function
and then I'll say
ampersand
create another parenthesis I'll see
athletes underscore DF
this time we'll consider the weight
column
again I'll use the function as not null
and
I'll close the parenthesis
okay I had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now all right
now we are going to create our final
plot I'll say PLT dot figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to
I'll say 12 comma 10
I'll say
access
equal to
SNS Dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
I'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis I'll have
height
comma
in my y-axis I'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore metals
comma
I'll use Hue equal to my sex column
cool
finally I'll say PLT dot I'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
Olympic
medalist
cool
now let's see our scatter plot this
might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
Hue which is for male and female there
you go
so if I scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot on the top
we have the title of the plot saying
height versus wheat of Olympic medalist
you can see
are each as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on Olympics data set
analysis
so we used two data sets to
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we created some visualizations to
analyze and visualize the data
all right
hello and welcome to data analytics
interview questions
my name is Richard kirschner with the
simply learned team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead
today we're going to jump into some
common questions you might see on numpy
arrays and pandas data frames in the
python along with some Excel Tableau and
SQL
let's start with our first question what
is the difference between Data Mining
and data profiling
it's real important to note that data
mining is a process of finding relevant
information which has not been found
before it is a way in which raw data is
turned into valuable information you can
think of this as anything from the sales
stats and from their SQL Server all the
way to web scraping and Census Bureau
information where the heck do you mine
it from where do you get all this data
and information
then we look at data profiling is
usually done to assess a data set for
its uniqueness consistency and logic it
cannot identify incorrect or inaccurate
data values so if somebody has a
statistical analysis on one side and
they're doing their you might in the
wrong data to then program your data
setup so you got to be aware that when
you're talking about data mining you
need to look at the Integrity of what
you're bringing in where it's coming
from data profiling is looking at it and
saying hey how is this going to work
what's the logic what's the consistency
is it related to what I'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics data wrangling is a process of
cleaning structuring and enriching the
raw data into a desired usable format
for better decision making
and you can see a nice chart here with
our Discover it we structure the data
how we want it we clean it up get rid of
all those null values we enrich it so we
might take and reformat some of the
settings instead of having five
different terms for height of somebody
you know in American English or whatever
clean some of that up and we might do a
calculation and bring some of them
together
and validate I was just talking about
that in the last one need to validate
your data make sure you have a solid
data source and then of course it goes
into the analysis very important to
notice here in data wrangling 80 percent
of data analytics is usually in this
whole part of wrangling the data getting
it to fit correctly and don't confuse
that with data cooking which is actually
when you're going into neural networks
cooking the data so it's all between
zero and one values
what are common problems that data
analysts encounter during analysis
handling duplicate and missing values
collecting the meaningful right data the
right time making data secure in dealing
with compliance issues handling data
purging and storage problems again we're
talking about data wrangling here eighty
percent of most jobs are in wrangling
that data and getting it in the right
format and making sure it's good data to
use
number four what are the various steps
involved in any analytics project
understand the problem we may spend 80
percent doing wrangling but you better
be ready to understand the problem
because if you can't you're going to
spend all your time in the wrong
direction this is probably uh the most
important part of the process everything
after it falls in and then you can come
back to it
two data collection data cleaning number
three four data exploration analysis and
five interpret the results
number five is a close second for being
the most important if you can't
interpret what you bring to the table to
your clients you're in trouble
so when this question comes up you
probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does 80 of
the work is in two three and four well
one and five are the most important
parts
which technical tools have you used for
analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools for
analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there SQL
Server MySQL you have your Excel your
SPSS which is the IBM platform tab blue
python you have all these different
Tools in here now certainly a lot of
jobs are going to be narrowed in on just
a few of these tools like you're not
going to have a Microsoft SQL Server
MySQL server but you better understand
how to do basic SQL polls it's also
understanding Excel and how the
different formats from column and how to
get those set up
number six what are the best practices
for data cleaning this is really
important to remember to go through this
in detail these always come up because
80 percent of most data analysis is in
cleaning the data make a data cleaning
plan by understanding where the common
errors take place and keep
Communications open identify and remove
duplicates before working with the data
this will lead to an effective data
analysis process focus on the accuracy
of the data maintain the value types of
data provide mandatory constraints and
set Cross Field validation
standardize the data at the point of
entry so it is less chaotic and you will
be able to ensure that all the
information is standardized leading to
fewer errors on Entry
number seven how can you handle missing
values in a data set list wise deletion
and listwise deletion method entire
record is excluded from analysis if any
single value is missing sometimes we're
talking about records remember this
could be a single line in a database so
if you have your SQL comes back and you
have 15 different columns every one of
those has a missing value you might just
drop it just to make it easy because you
already have enough data to do the
processing average imputation use the
average value of the responses from the
other participants to fill in the
missing value this is really useful and
they'll ask you why these are useful I
guarantee it if you have a whole group
of data that's collected and it doesn't
have that information in it at that
point you might average it in there
regression substitution you can use
multiple regression analysis to estimate
a missing value that kind of goes with
the average imputation input regression
model means you're just going to get
you're going to actually generate create
a prediction as to what you think that
value should be for those people based
on the ones you do have
multiple imputation so we talk about
multiple inputs it creates plausible
values based on the correlations for the
missing data and then average the
simulated data sets by incorporating
random errors in your predictions
what do you understand by the term
normal distribution and the second you
hear the word normal distribution should
be you think in a bell curve like we see
here normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution will appear as
a bell curve the mean median and mode
are equal that's a quick way to know if
you have normal distribution is you can
compute mean median and mode all of them
are located at the center of the
distribution 68 of the data lies within
one standard deviation of the mean 95
percent of the data Falls within two
standard deviations of the mean
99.7 of the data lies within three
what is time series analysis
time series analysis is a statistical
method that deals with ordered sequence
of values of a variable of equally
spaced time intervals time series data
on a covid-19 cases and you can see
we're looking at by days so our spaces
of days and each day goes by if we take
a graph it you can see the time series
graph always looks really nice if you
have like two different in this case we
have what the United States going over
there I'd have to look at the other
setup in there but they picked a couple
different countries and it is it's time
sensitive you know the next result is
based on what the last one was Cove is
an excellent example of this anytime you
do any word analytics where you're
figuring out what someone's saying what
they said before makes a huge difference
is what they're going to say next
another form of Time series analysis
10. how is joining different from
blending in tableau so now we're going
to jump into the Tableau package data
joining data joining can only be done
when the data comes from the same Source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same Excel file all the combined
tables or sheets contains common set of
dimensions and measures
data blending data blending is used when
the data is from two or more different
sources combining the Oracle table with
the SQL server or two sheets from Excel
or combining Excel sheet and Oracle
table in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions and
measures
how is overfitting different from
underfitting how he's a good one
overfitting probably the biggest danger
in data analytics today is overfitting
model trains from the data too well
using the training set
the performance drops significantly over
the test set happens when the model
learns the noise and random fluctuations
in the training data set in detail
and again the performance drops way
below what the test set has
the model neither trains a data well nor
can generalize to new data performs
poorly both on train and the test set
happens when there is less data to build
and an accurate model and also when we
try to build a linear model with a
non-linear data
in Microsoft Excel a numeric value can
be treated as a text value if it
proceeds with an apostrophe definitely
not an exclamation if you're used to
programming in Python you'll look for
that hash code and not an Amber sign
and we can see here if you enter the
value 10 into a fill but you put the
apostrophe in front of it it will read
that as a text not as a number
what is the difference between count
count a count blank and count if in
Excel
we can see here when we run in just
count D1 through D 23 we get 19 and
you'll notice that there is 19 numbers
coming down here
and so it doesn't count the cost of each
which is a top bracket it doesn't count
the blank spaces either with the
straight count
when you do a count a you'll get the
answer is 20. so now when you do count a
it counts all of them even the title
cost of each
when you do count blank we'll get three
why there's three blank fields
and finally the count if if we do count
F of e 1 to e23 is greater than 10
there's 11 values in there basic
counting of whatever's in your column
pretty solid on the table there
explain how vlookup Works in Excel
vlookup is used when you need to find
things in a table or a range by row
the syntax has four different parts to
it we have our lookup value that's the
value you want to look up we have our
table array
the range where the lookup value is
located
column index number the column number
and range that contains the return value
and the range lookup specify true if you
want an approximate match or false if
you want an exact match of the return
value
so here we see vlookup F3 A2 to C8 2
comma zero for prints now they don't
show the F3 F3 is the actual cell that
prints is in that's what we're looking
at is F3 so there's your prints he pulls
in from F3 A2 to C8 is the the data
we're looking into and then number two
is a column in that data so in this case
we're looking for uh age and we count
name as one age is two keep in mind this
is Excel versus a lot of your Python and
programming languages where you start at
zero in Excel we always look at the
cells as one two three so two represents
the age
0 is false for having an exact match up
versus one we don't actually need to
worry about that too much in this 0 or 1
would work with this example and you can
see with the Angela lookup again her
name would be in the F column number
four that's what the F4 stands for as we
where they pulled Angela from and then
you have A1 to C8 and then we're looking
at number three so number three is
height name being one H2 and then height
three and you'll see here it pulls in
her height 5.8
so we're going to run jump over to SQL
how do you subset or filter data in SQL
to subset or filter data in SQL we use
where and having clause and you can see
we have a nice table on the left where
we have the title the director the year
the duration we want to filter the table
for movies that were directed by Brad
Bird why just because we want to know
who what Brad Bird did so we're going to
do select star you should know that the
star refers to all in this case we're
what are we going to return we're going
to return all title directory year and
duration that's what you mean by all for
from movies movies being our table where
director equals Brad Bird and you can
see he comes back and he did the
incredible and Ratatouille
to subcenter filter data SQL we can also
use the where and having Clause so we're
going to take a closer look at the
different ways we can filter here filter
the table for directors whose movies
have an average duration greater than
115 minutes so there's a lot of really
cool things into this SQL query and
these SQL queries can get pretty crazy
select director sum duration as total
duration average duration as average
duration from movies Group by director
having average duration greater than
115.
uh so again what are we going to return
we're going to return whenever we put in
our select which in this case is
director we're going to have total
duration and that's going to be the sum
of the duration we're going to have the
average duration average underscore
duration which is going to be the
average duration on there and then we of
course go ahead and group by director
and we want to make sure we group them
by anyone that has an having an average
duration greater than 115. these SQL
queries are so important I don't know
how many times you the SQL comes up and
there's so many different other
languages not just MySQL and not
Microsoft SQL but in addition to that
where the SQL language comes in
especially with Hadoop in other areas so
you really should know your basic SQL
doesn't hurt to get that little cheat
sheet and glance over it and double
check some of the different features in
SQL
what is the difference between where and
having clause and SQL where where Clause
works on row data in where Clause a
filter occurs before any groupings are
made aggregate conscience cannot be used
so the syntax is select your columns
from table where what the condition is
having Clause works on aggregated data
having is used to filter values from a
group aggregate functions can be used
in the syntaxes select column names from
table where the condition is grouped by
having a condition ordered by column
names
what is the correct Syntax for reshape
function in numpy so we're going to jump
to the numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have in
this case be numpy.reshape a lot of
times you do an import numpy as NP
reshape and then your array and the new
shape
and you can see here as we as the actual
example comes in the reshape is a and
we're going to reshape it in two comma
five setups and you can see the print
out in there that prints in two rows
with five values in each one
what are the different ways to create a
data frame in pandas
well we can do it by initializing a list
so you can Port your pandas as PD very
common data equals Tom 30 jerry20 Angela
35 we'll go ahead and create the data
frame and we'll say
pd.dataframe is the data columns equals
name and age so you can designate your
columns you can also it is a index in
there you should always remember that
the index
in this case maybe you want the index
instead of one two to be the date they
signed up or who knows you know whatever
and you can see right there it just
generates a nice pandas data frame with
Tom Jerry and Angela another way you can
initialize a data frame is from
dictionary you can see here we have a
dictionary where the date equals name
Tom Jerry Angela Mary ages 20 21 1918
and if we do a DF PD dot data frame on
the data you'll get a nice the same kind
of setup you get your name age Tom Jerry
Angela and Mary
write the python code to create an
employee's data frame from the
emp.csv file and display the head and
summary of it
to create a data frame in Python you
need to import the pandas library and
use the read CSV function to load the
CSV file
and here you can see we have import
pandas's PD employees or the data frame
employees equals pd.read CSV and then
you have your path to that CSV file
there's a number of settings in the read
CSV where you can tell it how many rows
are the top index you can set the
columns in there
you can have skip rows there's all kinds
of things you can also go in there and
double check with your read CSV but the
most basic one is just to read a basic
CSV
how will you select the department and
age columns from an employee's data
frame
so we have import pandas is PD you can
see we have created our data we will go
ahead and create our employees PD data
frame on the left
and then on the right to select
department and age from the data frame
we just do employees you put the
brackets around it now if you're just
doing one column you could do just
department but if you're doing multiple
columns you've got to have those in a
second set of brackets so it's got to be
a reference with a list within the
reference
what is the criteria to say whether a
developed data model is good or not a
good model should be intuitive
insightful and self-explanatory follow
the old saying kiss keep it simple
the model developed should be able to
easily consumed by the clients for
actionable and profitable results
so if they can't read it what good is it
a good model should easily adapt to
changes according to business
requirements we live in quite a dynamic
world nowadays so it's pretty
self-evident and if the data gets
updated the model should be able to
scale accordingly to the new data so you
have a nice data pipeline going where
when something when you get new data
coming in you don't have to go and
rewrite the whole code
what is the significance of exploratory
data analysis
exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process exploratory data analysis Eda
helps to understand the data better it
helps you obtain confidence in your data
to a point where you're ready to engage
a machine learning algorithm it allows
you to refine your selection of feature
variables that will be used later for
model building you can discover hidden
Trends and insights from the data
how do you treat outliers in a data set
an outlier is a data point that is
distant from other similar points they
may be due to variability in the
measurement or may indicate experimental
errors
one you can drop the outlier records
pretty straightforward you can cap your
outliers data so it doesn't go past a
certain value you can assign it a new
value you can also try a new
transformation to see if those outliers
come in if you transform it slightly
differently
explain descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics descriptive
provides insights into the past to
answer what has happened uses data
aggregation and data mining techniques
examples an ice cream company can
analyze how much ice cream was sold
which flavors were sold and whether more
or less ice cream was sold than before
predictive understands the future to the
answer what could happen uses
statistical models and forecasting
techniques
the example predicts a sale of ice
creams during the summer spring and
rainy days uh so this is always
interesting because you have your
descriptive which comes in and your
businesses are always looking to know
what happened hey did we have good sales
last uh quarter what are we expecting
next quarter in the sales and we have a
huge jump when we do uh prescriptive
suggest various courses of action to
answer what should you do uses
optimization and simulation algorithms
to advise possible outcomes example
lower prices to increase sell of ice
creams produce more or less quantities
of certain flavor of ice cream and we
can certainly uh today's world with the
coveted virus because we had that in our
earlier graph you could see that as a
descriptive what's happened how many
people have been infected how many
people have died in an area predictive
where do we predict that to go
um do we see it going to get worse is it
going to get better what do we predict
that we're going to need in hospital
beds and prescriptive what can we change
in our setup do you have a better
outcome maybe if we did more social
distancing if we tracked the virus
how do these different things directly
affect the end and can we create a
better ending by changing some
underlying criteria
what are the different types of sampling
techniques used by data analysis
sampling is a statistical method to
select a subset of data from an entire
data set population to estimate the
characteristics of the whole population
one we can do a simple random sampling
so we can just pick out 500 random
people in the United States to sample
them
they call it a population in regular
data we also call that a population just
because that's where it came from was
mainly from doing census
systematic sampling
cluster sampling
stratified sampling and judgment or
purposive sampling
then we have our systematic sampling
that's where you're doing like uh using
one five ten fifteen twenty use a very
systematic approach for pulling samples
uh from the setup cluster sampling
that's where we look at it and we say
hey some of these things just naturally
group together if you were talking about
population which is the really a nice
way of looking at this cluster sampling
would be maybe by a zip code we're going
to do everybody's zip code and just
naturally cluster it that way
stratified sampling would be more
looking for shared things a group has
like income so if you're studying
something on poverty you might look at
their naturally group People based on
income to begin with and then study
those individuals in the income to find
out what kind of traits they have
and then judgmental that is where the
researcher very carefully selects each
member of their own group
so it's very much based on their
personal knowledge
jumping on the 26th what are the
different types of hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a procedure used
by estheticians and scientists to accept
or reject statistical hypothesis we
start with a hypothesis testing we have
null hypothesis and alternative
hypothesis
on the null hypothesis it states that
there is no relation between the
predictor and the outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by H naught
example there is no association between
patients BMI and diabetes alternative
hypothesis it states there is some
relation between the predictor and
outcome variables in the population it
is denoted by H1 example there could be
an association between patients BMI and
diabetes
and that's the body mass index if you
didn't catch the BMI and you're not
Medical
describe univariate bivariate and
multivariate Analysis
a unit variate analysis it is the
simplest form of data analysis where the
data being analyzed contains only one
variable an example of studying the
heights of players in the NBA because
it's so simple it can be described using
Central Tendencies dispersion quartiles
bar charts histograms pie charts
frequency distribution tables
the bivariate analysis it involves
analysis of two variables to find causes
relationships and correlations between
the variables example analyzing sale of
ice creams based on the temperature
outside
bivariate analysis can be explained
using correlation coefficients linear
regression logistic regression Scatter
Plots and box plots
and multivariate Analysis it involves
analysis of three or more variables to
understand the relationship of each
variable with the other variables
example analyzing Revenue based on
expenditure so if we have our TV ads we
have our newspaper ads our social media
ads and our Revenue we can now compare
all those together the multiverted
analysis can be performed using multiple
regression factor analysis
classification and regression trees
cluster analysis principle component
analysis clustering bar chart dual axis
chart
what function would you use to get the
current date and time in Excel
in Excel you can use the today and now
function to get the current date and
time and you can see down here with the
two examples where just equals today or
equals now
using the sum ifs function in Excel find
the total quantity sold by cells
Representatives whose name start with a
and the cost of each item they have sold
is greater than 10.
and you can see here on the left we have
our actual table
and then we want to go ahead and sumifs
so we want the E2 through E20
B2 through B20 greater than 10. and this
basically is just saying hey we're going
to take everything in the E column
and we're going to sum it up but only
those objects where the D column is
greater than 10 that's what that means
there
with the below query correct if not how
will you Rectify it
select customer ID year order date as
order Year from order where order year
is greater than or equal to 2016.
and hopefully you caught it right there
it's in the devils in the details we
can't not use the Alias name while
filtering data using the where Clause so
the correct format is all the same
except for where it says where the year
order date is greater than or equal to
16 versus using the order year which we
assign under the select setup
how are union intersect and accept used
in SQL
the union operator is used to combine
the results of two or more select
statements
and you can see here we have select star
from region one and we're going to make
a union with select star from region two
and it basically takes both these SQL
tables and combines them to form a full
new table on there so that's your union
as we bring everything together
when we look at the intersect operator
Returns the common records that are the
result of the two or more select
statements
so you can see here we select star from
region one intersect select star from
region two
and we come up with only those records
that are shared that have the same data
in them
and hopefully you jumped ahead to the
accept the accept operator returns The
Uncommon records that are the result of
two or more select statements so these
are the two records or the records that
are not shared between the two databases
using the product price table write an
SQL query to find the record with the
fourth highest market price
so here we have a little bit of a brain
teaser
they're always fun
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to go ahead and I'm going to
if you look at the script on the left we
really want the fourth one down so we're
going to select the top four from
product price but we're going to order
it by Marketplace descending SP order by
market price ascending
so we do is we take the top four of the
market price ascending and that's going
to give us the four greatest values
and then we're going to reverse that
order and do descending and we're going
to take the top one of that which is
going to give us the lowest value which
will be the fourth greatest one in the
list
from the product price table find the
total and average market price for each
currency where the average market price
is greater than 100 and currency is in
the INR or the AUD
so INR or AUD India Rupal or Australia
dollar
you can see over here the SQL query if
you had trouble putting this together
you might actually do some of it in
reverse and you can see right here where
the average market price is greater than
50. remember we use having not where at
the end because it's part of the group
so Group by currency because we want
those two currencies and we want the
currency India the INR or the AUD and as
you keep going backwards we're actually
going to be selecting the currency the
sum of the market price as total price
and the average Marketplace as average
price so there's our select it's going
to come from the product price which is
just our table over there and then we
have where our currency is in and like I
said you can put together however you
want but hopefully you got to the end
there
so this question will test your
knowledge in Tableau exploring the
different features of Tableau and
creating a suitable graph to solve a
business problem
and of course tab blue is very visual in
its use so it's very hard to test it
without actually just getting your hands
on and if you can't visualize some of
this and how to do it then you should go
back and refresh yourself
using the sample Superstore data set
Create A View to analyze the cells
profits and quantities sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each category so the first step is
to go ahead and load the sample
Superstore data set
so make sure you know how to load the
sample the superstore data set that's
underneath either the connect button in
the upper left or the Tableau icon up
there and be able to pull in the data
set and then once you've done that you
just drag the category and subcategory
on rows and salaries onto columns it
will result in a horizontal bar chart
so in this one we're just going to drag
profit onto color and quantity onto
label sort the sales axes in descending
order of sum and cells within each
subcategory
and if you're at home doing this you'll
see the chairs in their Furniture
category have the highest sales and
profit while tables had the lowest
profit for office supplies subcategory
binders made the highest profit even
though storage had the highest sales
under technology category copiers made
the highest profit though it was the
least amount of sales
let's work to create a dual axis chart
in Tableau to present cells and profits
across different years using sample
Superstore data set
load the orders sheet from the sample
drag the ordered data field from the
dimensions onto columns and convert it
into continuous months
drag cells onto rows and profits to the
right corner of the view until you see a
light green rectangle one of those
things if you haven't done this Hands-On
you don't know what you're doing you're
already into a bank so you can be just
kind of dropping it and wondering what
happened synchronize the right Axis by
right-clicking on the profit axis
and then let's finalize it by going
under the marks card change some cells
to bar and some profit to line and
adjust the size
and then we have a nice display that we
can either print out or save and send
off to the shareholders
let's go and do one more Tableau design
a view in Tableau to show Statewide
cells and profits using the sample
Superstore data set
and here you go ahead and drag the
country field onto the view section and
expand it to see the states drag the
states field onto size and profit onto
color
increase the size of the Bubbles at a
border and a Halo color States like
Washington California and New York have
the highest sales and profits while
Texas Pennsylvania and Ohio have a good
amount of sales but the least amount of
profits
we'll go ahead and Skip back to python
numpy Suppose there is an array number
equals NP or numpy if you're using numpy
depending on how you set it up dot array
and we just have one to nine broken up
into three groups extract the value 8
using 2D indexing so you can see on the
left we have our import numpy is in p
number equals our NP array if we print
the number we have one two three four
five six seven eight nine
since the value 8 is present in the
second row and First Column we use the
same index position and pass it to the
array and you just have number two comma
one and you get eight and remember we're
in Python so you start at zero not one
like you do in Excel
always kiss me if I'm working between
Excel and python where I just kind of
flip and usually it's the Excel that
messes up because I do a lot more
programming
Suppose there is an array that has value
0 1 all the way up to 9. how will you
display the following values from the
array one three five seven nine
uh so first of all we go ahead and
create the array NP dot a range of 10
which goes from 0 to 9 because there's
ten numbers in it but we don't include
the 10. we print it out the first thing
you want to do is what's going on here
with one three five seven nine well if
we divide by 2 there's going to be a
remainder equal to one and then from
python remember that if you use the
percentage sign you get the remainder on
there so the remainder is one and then
you have the your numpy array and then
we just want to do a logical statement
of all values that have a remainder of 1
and that generates our nice one three
five seven nine
and
there are two arrays A and B stack the
arrays A and B horizontally boy these
horizontal vertical questions will get
you every time
and in numpy we go ahead and we've
created two different arrays over here A
and B the first one is your concatenate
NP dot concatenate
A and B on axes equal one
that is the same as H stack and in the
back end they're still identical they
run the same that's all each stack is a
concatenate axes equals one
how can you add a column to a panda's
data frame
suppose there's an imp data frame that
has information about few employees
let's add address column to that data
frame and you can see in the left we
have our basic data frame you should
know your data frames very well
basically looks like an Excel
spreadsheet as you come over here it's
really simple you just do DF of address
equals the address once you've assigned
values to the address
using the below given data create a
pivot table to find the total cells made
by each cells represented for each item
display the cells as a percentage of the
grand total
so we're back in Tableau select the
entire table range click on insert Tab
and choose pivot table
select the table range and the worksheet
where you want to place the pivot table
it will return a pivot table where you
can analyze your data
drag the cell total on the values and
sales rep and item onto row labels it'll
give the sum of the cells made by each
representative for each item they have
sold
and finally right click on sum of cell
total and expand show values as to
select percentage of grand total
uh real important just understand what a
pivot table is we're just pivoting it
from rows and columns and switching this
direction on there
and finally we have our final pivot
table and you can see the values rolls
and sum of total sale
so we're going to go ahead and take a
product table this is off of an SQL so
we're going to do some SQL here
and we're going to use the product and
sales order detail table find the
products that have total units sold
greater than 1.5 million and here's our
sales order detail table so we have a
product table and a sales order detail
table two separate tables in the
database
and we're going to do is put together
the SQL query we want to select PP name
sum sod unit price as cells and then we
have our p p dot product ID from
production product as PP inner join
cells.sales order detail as sod on PP
product ID equals sod.product ID Group
by pp.name comma pp.product ID having a
sum of sod.uniprice greater than the 150
million there that's a mouthful and
again these SQL queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break them apart and do them step by
step
and what we're looking for is the inner
join and how did you do the group by
this really wanted to know how do you do
this inner join this comes up so much in
SQL uh how do you pull in the ID from
one chart and the information from
another chart and the sum totals on that
chart
how do you write a stored procedure in
SQL let's create a storage procedure to
find the sum the squares or the first n
natural numbers so here we have our
formula n times n plus 1 times 2N plus 1
over 6. and you can see from the command
prompt uh or the setup you have which
depending on what your login is the
command is create procedure Square sum1
declare our variable at n of integer as
begin then we're going to declare the
sum of integer set sum equals n times n
plus 1 plus 2 times n plus 1 over 6.
of course we can go ahead and print
those out print First cast
member sign in or our variable as a
variable character 20 natural numbers
parenthesis sum of the square is cast
the at sum as a variable character 40
and then we do the output display the
sum of the square for first four natural
numbers we have execute Square sum 1 and
then we're going to put in 4 and you can
see here where it brings up the first
four natural numbers sum of square is
30.
write a store procedure to find the
total even number between two user given
numbers
couple things to note here first we go
and create our procedure you have your
two different variables the N1 N2 and we
go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to zero
and then we have while n is less than N2
we're going to begin and if N1 remainder
2 equals 0 so we're going to divide it
by two even number begin we're going to
set the count equal to count plus one
we're going to print even number plus
cast n as a variable character 10 for
printing count is plus cast variable
count as variable character 10 end else
print odd number plus cast variable
number one as variable character ten and
then we go ahead and set the increment
our variable one up one so it'll go from
in one all the way to N2 and I'll print
the total number of even numbers
and you can see here we went ahead and
executed it we're going to count the
even numbers between 30 and 45 and you
see it goes all the way down to eight
what is the difference between tree maps
and heat maps in tableau
now if you've worked in Python other
programmings you should automatically
know what a heat map is but a tree map
are used to display data in nested
rectangles use Dimensions to define the
structure of the tree map and measure to
define the size or color of individual
rectangles
tree maps are relatively simple data
visualization that can provide Insight
in a visually attractive format
and again you can see the squares over
here this is our tree map over here with
the each block also has this information
inside of its different blocks
a heat map helps to visualize measures
against Dimensions with the help of
colors and size to compare one or more
dimensions and up to two measures the
layout is similar to a text table with
variations in values encoded as colors
in heat map you can quickly see a wide
array of information
and in this one uh you can see they use
the colors to denote one thing and the
size of the little square to denote
something else
a lot of times you can even graph this
into a three-dimensional graph with
other data so it pops out but again a
heat map is the color and the size
using the sample Superstore data set
display the top five and bottom five
customers based on their profit so you
start by dragging the customer name
field onto rows and profit on columns
right click on the customer name column
to create a set
give a name to the set and select top
tab to choose top 5 customers by some
profit similarly create a set for the
bottom five customers by some profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set give a name to the
set and choose all members in both sets
and then you can drag top and bottom
customer sets onto the filters and
profit field onto color to get the
desired results
as we get down to the end of our list
we're going to try to keep you on your
toes we're going to skip back to numpy
how to print four random integers
between 1 and 15 using numpy to Generate
random numbers using numpy we use a
random random integer function and you
see here we did the import numpy as in p
random Arrangement equals np.random dot
random integer 1 through 15 of 4.
from the below data frame I'm going to
jump again on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for age
less than 35 and height greater than 6.
to find the unique values and the number
of unique elements use the unique and
the in unique function
you can see here we just did DF Heights
we're selecting just the height column
and we want to look for The Unique that
returns an array or in unique if we do
that on the height or the age we'll
return just the number of unique values
and then we can do a subset the data for
ages less than 35 and height greater
than 6. so if we look over here we have
a new DF remember this is going to be
taking slices of our original data frame
it doesn't actually change the data
frame so our new DF equals the data
frame or DF the data frame where age is
less than 35
and the height is greater than 6.
and in case you're not using uh tab blue
which has a lot of its own uh different
mapping programs in there make sure you
understand how to use the basics of
matplot Library plot a sine graph using
numpy and matplot library in Python and
the way we did this is we went ahead and
generated an X we know our y equals NP
dot sine of x if you print out X you'll
see a whole value here our matplot
library Pi plot as PLT if you are
working in Jupiter notebook make sure
you understand the matplot library
inline that little percentage sign
matplot Library Online that prints it on
the page in the Jupiter notebook the
newer version of jupyter notebook or
Jupiter Labs automatically does that for
you but I usually put it in there just
in case I end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
X values
you simply put in plt.plot x y and do a
plot show
and before we go let's get one more in
we're going to do a pandas using the
below pandas data frame find the company
with the highest average cells derive
the summary statistics for the cells
column and transpose these statistics
that's a mouthful and just like any of
these computer problems break it apart
so first of all we're looking for the
highest average cells so group the
company column and use the mean function
to find the average cells you see here
by company equals df.group by company
thank you once we've done that using the
describe function we can now go ahead
and look at the summary of statistics on
here use the describe function to find
the summary so by company those are
groups we're just going to describe them
and you can actually bundle those
together if you wanted and just do a
Mullen one line so here we go by company
dot describe you can see we have a nice
breakout always good to remember whether
you're using any of the packages whether
it's tab blue or pandas in python or
even r or some other package being able
to quick look and describe your data is
very important
and then we go ahead and just do a basic
apply a transpose function over the
describe method to transpose the
statistics
all we've done here is flip the index
with the column names but if you're
following the numbers a lot of times
it's easier to follow across one line or
maybe you want to average out the count
or it's all kinds of different reasons
to do that and with that we have come to
the end of this video tutorial on data
analytics full course 2022 by simply
lowen I hope it was really helpful and
informative thank you and keep learning